hop
[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe à tout d'un
coup tu me parles de quoi la radio ou à
la télé les journaux tout le monde en
face à le truc mais oui ce matin chez
lui au petit matin les amis du samedi
soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez leur honda fit le voici
alors merci bonsoir qu'elle accueille un
bonsoir oui merci beaucoup
alors laurent vous monter une pièce y
paraît oui non j'ai écrit une pièce qui
devrait se jouer rarement et comment ça
s'appelle sexe magouille et culture
générale et sur la télé alors fait sur
la télé c'était l'histoire d'un jeu télé
donc et du sexe de la magouille et un
peu de culture je suis un peu comme ici
un peu comme ici finalement laurent est
ce que vous avez déjà choisi vos acteurs
pour cette pièce
oui bon daniel russo à daniel russo et
pascal sellem mado maurin mado maurin la
maman de adam devers moi la culture
générale c'est bien ce que j'avais dit
alors mise à part laurent baffie je
recevrai ce soir gérard darmon le civil
main
tejpal mal
luc guyau
isabelle boulay
jean marie
et guy forget
ça fait du monde on revient avec les
courriers des lits téléspectateurs c'est
une idée dont comme je vous le disais
qui a été très apprécié on a reçu des
emails de france bien sûr mais aussi du
maroc du sénégal je salue banon qui nous
écrit du sénégal voilà qui s'appelle le
jedi fou alors lui il aime bien ça lui
la médiation
wendy brown ni ses formidables donc je
dis à tous nos amis téléspectateurs que
ccqs l'eau de bec il dit est-ce que
c'est toi qui choisis je réponds non
c'est ma femme est ce que c'est toi qui
lis les emails et toi qui répond je dis
oui
la preuve c'est bien moi qui réponds et
alors je vais vous dire simplement il ya
beaucoup d'émissions avec 2 m
alors j'ai dit ok mission ça prend qu'un
seul mm sur internet est d'ailleurs
nicolas gilbert se reconnaîtra je pense
à nicolas alors il ya quelqu'un qui
s'appelle saint génis est bizarre c'est
vrai c'est un pseudo ou un nom qui me
dit est ce que tu fais tes fiches seul
nom j'ai des journalistes qui m'aident à
récolter l'information après je prépare
mes interviews et mes fiches bah oui je
les fais seule je les écris j'ai écrit à
la main tout seul pendant pendant de
longues nuits comme ça assez incroyable
salaires modiques permettait à rbo tabou
alors même question toujours du même qui
me dit pourquoi tu a invité les toubitri
ben oui pourquoi j'y réponds maintenant
non je réponds ce que je trouve un sens
et c'est que les to be tri de temps en
temps ils vont dîner chez la femme de
l'écrivain louis-ferdinand céline et
donc d'un coup je me dis que ça va être
incroyable sedin et je voulais leur
poser la question voilà c'est tout j'ai
une curiosité des fois très très précis
connaît très bien et tous mes flèches je
fais deux émissions avec eux ils sont
beaucoup moins conques alliage
alors pourquoi est-ce que tu m'invites
pas guy bedos me demande isabelle
regnier d'un quand il veut un glisser
votre copain guy bedos moi je les adore
c'est pas moi mais j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui moi aussi we be
pourquoi tu viens pas j'ai beaucoup
donné physiquement parce que ça fait dix
ans que te dit partout qu'il est mort
voilà non je dis pas qu'il est mort j'ai
commencé en disant qu'il y avait une
perruque
alors y'a stella qui me dit qu'elle
s'effriter avec son ami au sujet des
mannequins les top modèles qui sont à
l'émission parce que son mec lui disais
mais ardisson les invite pour faire de
l'audimat et stella qui est une vraie
fidèles de l'émission dit pas du tout
c'est pas le genre d'ardisson allait
bien c'était là à l'école alors bien
habile qui me dit chérie avec votre
histoire de vie courrier dei
téléspectateurs vous aurez plus de
reproches que de compliments
oui je re a des reproches il ya de quoi
y compris mme henry alors il ya eric
pork mais avec la porte avec un q lui il
me dit toute façon les animateurs télé
ils ont tellement peur qu'on les prenne
pour des feignants ils ont des scrupules
donc là tu t'es cru obligé d'inventer
3,4 truqué le championnat de france de
blague c'est pas vraiment une bonne idée
les blagues c'est le truc qui sauve les
soirées ratées ton émission a pas besoin
de saab on verra j'ai des reproches mais
j'ai aussi des compliments donc j'essaie
si la dalle mère qui me dit on vous
remercie thierry ardisson parce que vous
ne prenez pas tous les français pour des
moutons télévisuel c'est vrai voilà
comment peut-on assister à l'émission
c'est écrit en bas de l'écran pendant
que je le dis voilà magie de la
télévision
et puis dernière chose c'est pas une spa
ni mail c'est une lettre c'est une
lettre de delphine thomas qui m'a envoyé
une très gentille lettre et je voulais
simplement lui répondre ça
g
c
voilà ses portes à delphine et courage
bien alors jean marie bigard était avec
nous samedi dernier ici on a on a des
airs regarder le sketch dont vous êtes
le co auteur il y avait donc patrick
poivre d'arvor avec jean marie bigard et
patrick poivre d'arvor
on a parlé à un moment du film de
jean-marie l'âme soeur que vous avez vu
laurent j'imagine trois fois j'étais
punie et bien ppda on a dit le plus
grand bien
moi j'ai aimé le film de jean marie
bigard parce qu'il a voulu écrire
quelque chose il l'a dit malheureusement
peu de gens l'ont vu chez eux mais l'on
peut importe il a dit ça voilà c'est un
petit amant mais peut-être chez point
dans 30 ans à repassera voilà c'était
donc patrick poivre d'arvor qui
s'exprimait la semaine dernière le sujet
du film de jean-marie bigard alors j'en
arrive à raconter des histoires de
blanche mais si l'histoire de blondes
c'est vrai c'est la mode alors j'en ai
reçus et parce que ma femme est blonde
donc évidemment un peu délicat alors
j'en ai une par exemple de ces covarel
donc c'est que des adresses emails bien
entendu pourquoi les blondes prennent la
pilule
vous savez ouais c'est pour savoir quel
jour on est alors j'en ai une florence
parly nt ce que met une blonde à ses
oreilles pour attirer les hommes
tes cuisses ses genoux
alors vous savez quand ces démissions il
ya une rubrique qui s'appelle tout le
monde en a parlé c'est le best of de
l'émission de la semaine passée ça n'a
pas changé
vous aimeriez avoir année supplémentaire
un hall supplémentaires un doigt un sexe
et si c'était un chèque supplémentaire
lequel le sexe de mon amant gaza le bras
d'honneur confrères gonzesses on aura un
sexe de femme pas loin juste l'intérieur
de l'église
qu'est ce que tu fais ben tu vois je
baise c'est très excitant il ya une
scène d'amour au bureau page 280 les
vies de gens d'acheter tout le livre
d'or vous allez vous connais l âge de
180 vous pensez pas que ça pourrait
faire un
sur tf1 ça ferait un film enfin un
téléfilm
oui mais enfin ça coûte cher parce qu'il
ya des costumes ouais on savait quoi
laisser sont un peu où j'en avais parlé
des 24 ans vous mesurer à m 118 kg et
les yeux bleus
non ça je dis pas tiens justement tour
de poitrine vous allez me dévoue j'suis
pas sa polaire d'été et 9,85 ça va non
non mais ça va
vous pensez qu'il faudrait que j'en ai
honte non non pas du tout pensé que les
chiens et les petites poitrines c'est
bien là la reformation de gare moi je
vais rentrer chez moi si je pouvais me
rendent mieux compte mais c'est possible
et après moyen de jeter un coup d'oeil
sénateurs non j'ai fait une petite
ambiance spéciale de plage le soir un
peu moins fort c'est la douche et mes
limites de la jeune dow est sécheresse
dom et demi déjà eu des grillons le tour
tu vois les chiottes et le maïs tasci
ouvert et on entend un peu des grillons
échelle doit elle fuit
quelle ambiance qui la reçoit veut
gagner des millions qui est des
gouverneurs éric boilard exemple alors
julio iglesias entend plan votre propre
frère christophe colomb exactement alors
la démarrante en glandes
c'est grave on l'a surtout vu en bd
c'est pas sûr qu'ils existent
mon frère c'est un concile avait
découvert quelque chose quand j'hésite
être lieu glisse vers sa demande l'avis
du public
excusez moi d'insister ça a l'air un
petit peu obsessionnel mais pas de sens
non plus vous êtes obsédé jeunesse de
saint christol ça vous dérange on va
parler par exemple on vous appelle
comanche à charles napoléon prince
monseigneur napo napo n'a comme vous
voulez un peu gens un peu dingue quoi
c'est en voyant mais j'ai participé et
60 charles
ouais d'accord
dix copains de serre il fait dépuceler
en fait par une prostituée noire
alors je signale la page 43 matchs de
180 ch et poires c'est l'amour sur un
bureau et le dépucelage de fumeurs c'est
c'est page 43 données avec jean des
tweets ce qui est étrange de les
entendre dire mais voilà on avait chanté
on avait été écoutée acheté par un
million deux cent mille personnes
et puis après on a appris à chanter sur
sortie de le faire de produits million
deux cent mille personnes qui ont cru
qu'ils chantent comme c'est la rentrée
michel dernier à faire une interview
rentrée ce qui pose des questions à nos
amis franck philippe et adèle cette fois
9 55 56 65 63
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ça c'est que j'ai pas compris
la question c'est certain recul
en fait on a foi cette [ __ ] 72 noms
dans ce qu'il faut dire à tous nos amis
téléspectateurs cette fois neuf c'est
comme neuf fois cette en fait ces trois
garçons mais c'est exactement la même
chose voilà bien alors maintenant on va
commencer sérieusement l'émission avec
[Musique]
dans son
c'est bien
c
tous cas moi
voici
jardin monde
gérard darmon mesdames messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir connaissez laurent baffie oui un
peu cela va à la folie comment vous
n'êtes pas fâché du tout pas du tout à
ça tombe bien ça j'avais trop faible un
petit moment là ouais je suis fâché avec
très peu de personnes par exemple y en a
beaucoup mais on va commencer tout de
suite bien alors gérard vous êtes
l'interprète de la réplique culte du
cultissime la cité de la peur d'alain
berbérian le le film de les nuls 1
c'était quoi la réplique c'était un
doigt deux c'était quoi servait c'était
deux doigts de whisky oui je juste deux
doigts voulait pas un peu de whisky
d'abord fait ses cultes alors vous avez
été étiqueté pendant de longues années
comme le mauvais garçon type wii vous ça
vous gêne pas qu'on vous dit ça parce
que c'est vrai je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai mais ça ne me gêne pas quand même
le dise même quand à l'époque c'était un
peu un peu plus vrai quand même un peu
plus brun un peu plus c'est vrai que la
plus agressif un peu moins bien dans ma
tête donc mais c'est vrai que vous avez
été l'exemple de l'intégration des brins
dans le cinéma français au début début
des années 80 quoi c'est bohringer berry
anconina il ya plein de mecs comme ça
qu'ils sont arrivés dans un univers où
il va encore des visages très régulier
blond aux yeux bleus de domenech la non
non non non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'il manque aux états unis avait pas de
chine où il y avait deux noms mais c'est
tout qui vont vers la la la et en france
n'existait pas puis un jour vous êtes
arrivé au crochet rhin comme yavé roger
hanin roger hanin c'est vrai était le
alors vous allez jouer en fait tous les
tous les rôles de [ __ ] comme disait
laurent très élevée qu'il est très
gentiment ouais vous allez israélien
vous avez été arabe au cinéma vous avez
été juste pied noir évidemment c'était
gitan dans le film les princes de tony
gatlif et les italiens ont été géorgiens
ont cité un peu spécialisés comme ça
dans les rôles du pas spécialisés c'est
les gens qui ont bien voulu
me spécialiser là dedans après les
princes et des gens dont le métier qui
me demander si j'étais vraiment gitans
ce qui était absurde et en même temps ce
qui est à remplir ces gens comprennent
mais vous dites par mon physique à
l'écran va vous avez dit par mon
physique à l'écran je lutte contre le
racisme est ce que vous croyez par
exemple quand blond aux yeux bleus et
milite pour le fascisme lui au cinéma ah
non mais j'ai pas dû lui dire une façon
aussi abrupte mais c'est vrai que j'ai
été confronté à des à des situations
comme ça où c'était ce qu'on peut vous
pouvez appeler ddd lingle quoi c'était
ça commence au conservatoire et vous
avez été barrée au conservatoire c'est
vrai cette histoire nous est absolument
mais je n'ai pas le physique maison
paris absolument insensé gérard darmon a
été élevé rue des artistes oui dans le
14e arrondissement ce qui était déjà
très prémonitoire et on le dimanche vous
alliez au bistrot avec votre oncle et
vous avez dans un bistrot y avait robert
cohen
il ya le célèbre champion de boxe et
vous réciter le loup et l'agneau pour 5
francs oui pour enfants une fille les
cinq balles d'un petit 1 victor hugo à
l'époque c'est les petits curieux
étaient une fortune
une fortune compteur on a parlé un petit
peu de votre vie j'ai rarement
oui
alors à l'école vous étiez la tête de
tueur marc avec la tête que vous avez
c'est un peu vous voyez que ça continue
vaille c'est quand il est voué là vous
êtes est viré parce que vous avez fait
chanter la madelon à toute la classe le
son serait rentrée c'est moi alors à 16
ans la veille de votre entrée en 1ère
vous dit à vos parents que voulait plus
aller au lycée ça aurait été un choc
terrible en précommande
ça peut être un choc absolu j'ai eu
quelques consignes avec qui j'ai eu bon
ça métier difficile
difficile de percer on ne savait pas il
faut des relations alors donc votre
décision de ne pas entrer en première ça
a été le début de dix ans de galère
oui sont des choses source d des pièces
qu'on répète des mois et des mois pour
gagner pour jouer quatre fois devant des
salles en général quand payant il de
vendre payant mais il y avait un alvaro
dedans il y avait il y avait tout ça
rend le film de joe louis et bacri
évidemment elles veulent aller sur scène
en finale qui joue dans une très bonne
pièce vers tours ce qu'on t'a fait voilà
et
bon bah ça démarre vraiment divac way
cap cana et gilberto les princes tony
gatlif notre histoire
le voleur et la menteuse avec mathilda
may oui c'est comment c'était vous étiez
déjà ensemble vous avez fait le film du
tout non plus connu pendant deux fils
oui oui allez vous faites partie des
artistes qui ont rencontré leurs femmes
sur leur lieu de travail
voilà ça m'est arrivé au moins une fois
donc oui je parle et ça ça pourra
peut-être arrivé ce soir
qui sait pardon moi je suis tout à fait
les bruits mais non tout ce qui est
garçon ma femme motoriste c'est vrai ça
c'est sympa ça passe à entre 13 et 17
ans fait partie d'un mouvement de
jeunesse sioniste le but comme ça c'est
de travailler dans un sens d'aller
travailler en israël dans un kibboutz ah
oui quand vous avez 15 ans vous prenez
le bateau et vous arriver un jour en
israël
six jours de voyage dans les six heures
du matin trois mois dans un kibboutz a
bossé je vais oublier aux ramassiers des
oranges non je faisais non c'est les
oranje s'étaient très sympathique je
faisais mon météo poulailler allez je
fais le poulailler c'est quinze mille
poules et râles théâtre on sortait plus
on sortait en poules en fait avec des
plumes et la mairie en communiquant très
peu avec les autres c'est déjà l'hébreu
je ne maîtrisais pas bien donc je
faisais cocorico quoi et qu'est ce qui
vous a déçu ce passage vous êtes vous
dit j'ai été déçu quand même par ces
mots dont je pas été déçus ce n'était
pas ma vie sans quoi on le sent en tout
les cas c'est l'effet prendre conscience
de votre votre identité vous vous dites
d'ailleurs j'ai fini de rêver parce que
quand j'étais petit je rêvais que
j'étais blond aux yeux bleus et là d'un
coup j'ai pris conscience de mon
identité ça a été fini quoi j'ai
commencé à me sentir mieux dans ce bien
dans ma peau
bien sûr on puisse y aller leur gêne
tout à fait naturel de l'adolescence
pour sortir du milieu dont on extrait
donc sept pieds noirs a donc à côté de
moi me
le révulse et je détestais l'accent j'ai
trouvé qu'on comme des balais
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez ce qui se
passe en israël c'est à dire ce
déchaînement finalement de 2 des
ultraorthodoxes quoi finalement de la
droite
est ce que pour vous c'est pas terrible
parce que de devoir qu'à cause de ces
gens là
finalement on risque de ne pas trouver
une solution au moyen-orient oui c'est
pas terrible mais moi je suis je passe
au dessus de ces de ces contingences là
et pardonnez moi c'est peut-être une
chose un peu un peu plus mystique mais
non non je pense que le le bien finit
toujours par par triompher quoi qu'il
arrive c'est que cette histoire entre
juifs et arabes et palestiniens en
l'occurrence va se forcément se résoudre
il ya quelques religieux qui pensent que
c'est d'ailleurs l'arrivée du messie sun
soit sera donc vous vous croyez quand
même malgré tout qu'une solution est
possible
je pense que c'est parce que là les
palestiniens devaient problème elles
sont elles si cette semaine en septembre
ils l'ont pas fait parce qu'ils veulent
pas d'une reconnaissance symbolique ils
disent attendre et nous hisser pour
reconnaître qu'on est indépendant
rien on veut que ce soit vraiment vrai
voilà vous n'êtes pas déçu par le fait
se sont encore repoussés
oui bon début de l'année prochaine bah
oui les bâtons dans les roues oui le
puits l'année prochaine nous y sommes
enfin bon quand on a attendu 2000 depuis
plus de 2000 ans peut être encore quinze
jours et vous avez raison mais vous êtes
vachement oecuméniques parce que vous
avez fait votre anniversaire j'étais le
29 février gérard darmon les cheveux
très secs avec khaled qui lui aussi est
né le 29 février dans google est plutôt
du genre vous c'est pour ça que je
parlais des orthodoxes tout à l'heure à
l'engagement est plutôt du genre
pacifiste enfin gauche et vosges
israélienne bon à faire un petit peu de
promo d'accord ok
bon alors gérard darmon est le coauteur
d'un livre qui sort chez michel lafon
qui s'appelle tu préfères trois petits
points à vie donc c'est écrit avec
pierre palmade qui va nous rejoindre de
tout à l'heure et on regardera le sketch
que vous avez écrit pour lui pour son
dernier spectacle on va pas dans des
bouquins en attendant gérard darmon va
faire une interview mensonge je
connaissais le principe d'interviews
mensonge il faut dire le contraire 2 au
contraire de la vérité
oui c'est pas c'est pas ça en conférant
la vérité ou de le contraire de ce qu'on
pense c'est fou ce qu'on pensait pas
jusque là vous pensez que vous pensez la
vérité reçus à bercy
non
[Applaudissements]
m
vous vous déplacez toujours en limousine
avec des vitres fumées et puis des gens
qui vous allume comme ça vos cigarettes
ouais ouais pourquoi c'est parce que ça
fait chic ça fait chier c'est d'ailleurs
vous pensez que vous êtes une star et
que vous devez avoir tous ses attributs
de la star études
c'est cela donne c'est quoi votre
voiture limousine votre la mer' course à
600 en vacances vous allez toujours
faire du tourisme sexuel en thaïlande
vous avez déclaré c'est ma façon de
participer au développement économique
du pays
si j'ai dit ça je ne peux je ne peux pas
me je ne peux pas dire le contraire mais
la revue et machin de nom je pourrais
vous partez seul à bangkok
pourquoi pas avec des amis vous êtes
mise en trois passes point là exactement
et ça fait partie de plaisir que je ne
partage pas donc je vous fais des choses
tellement inavouables là-bas que vous
pouvez pas partir c'est pas tellement
une voie puisque on peut en parler soit
on parle de tout et qu'un problème vous
a beaucoup vu cet été à saint-tropez
avec valérie kaprisky après mathilda may
c'est une espèce de spécialisation que
vous avez comme ça dans l'est on va dire
ça comme ça
oui oui ça se passe bien avec précaution
car si alors question c'est que vous
êtes beaucoup moins actif qu'avant s'est
déclaré dans match j'ai compris que
c'est dans les yeux que ça se passe
comment ça se fait c'est l'âge c'est les
cheveux blancs c'est la prostate ou
alors c'est simplement sa sérénité tout
simplement je pense un peu des quatre
jeunes femmes peut-être la prostate
c'est peut-être la prostate renvoie
beaucoup avec la bande de michel drucker
fait beaucoup de sport avec la bande de
michel drucker tous les jours je fais du
vélo à à longchamp avant de manger des
pâtes au beurre avec delon et belmondo
sont comme celui-ci tombe et vincent
lindon bac riches à ben arfa tous vos
copains pour pour la bande à drucker sel
soit non parce que je trouve
intellectuellement beaucoup plus faible
que la bande à laquelle vous faites
allusion au jeu d'un drôle
en définitive on un jeune que c'est plus
que ce fleuron
qu'elle vous faites allusion d'accord
vous vous avez une carrière honorable
finalement c'est pas malin votre
carrière
merci j'ai fait que ça ne fait que
commencer ça ne fait commencer ben oui à
votre âge avec voix 42 ans dans le même
sens vous êtes soutenus financièrement
fin par votre frère jean claude darmon
l'honneur dans le grand argentier du
foot
énorme il va vous subventionnez comme ça
pendant des années en tant que je tombe
lui demander tant que temps que j'arrive
à l'embrouillé a pas de problème
est ce que finalement c'est lui qui vous
a influencé de se faire arrêter de vous
droguez on peut le dire je crois que
c'est ça fait une semaine maintenant
vous avez rien prises 24 heures c'est
bien une semaine à ces gens arrêtent un
patch anti héroïne
voilà il ne vaut pas tu sais bien droit
gaucher d'accord le crack juste dans le
domaine philosophique surtout en
philosophie vous êtes très intéressé par
par nietzsche ou vous êtes un
nietzschéen sert le surhomme
tout à fait je partage l'opinion on a
mis le kiné oui c'est ça vous êtes
nietzschéen pour vous il ya des
surhommes et des sous à main c'est bien
ça que ça le reste c'est de la merde le
reste c'est de la merde vous dites alors
ça c'est très étonnant c'est la première
fois que je vois ça vous avez déclaré
cité dans el vous a déclaré j'aimerais
mourir comme presley pourquoi parce que
ça a duré longtemps parce qu'il était
gros plein d'eau plein d'allégresse mais
j'adore les sucreries
voilà si je peux mais tout fait en
bouffant je l'habille à saint louis
c'était l'interview
deux gendarmes et bien l'interview
mensonge ce que ça révèle la vraie
personne était résolument celle que
j'accueille maintenant triomphe dans le
film de dominik moll qui s'appelle harry
un ami qui vous veut du bien avec sergi
lopez et mathilde seigner
voici ce film a
donc bon soir me connaissent et gérard
darmon non non méfiez-vous latine leurs
liens attention lui c'est le latino
lover type pour tous maintenant qu'il a
les cheveux un peu plus grisonnant il
vous emballez plus non non et non c'est
non bon alors vous a découvert avec
l'ennui de cédric kahn avec charles
berling et arielle dombasle qui a eu le
prix louis delluc et justement on a
beaucoup dit enfin des gens 110 après
l'ennui est ce que c'est votre premier
film
est-ce que c'est l'actrice d'un rôle ou
est ce que finalement elle peut très
bien continuer une carrière au cinéma
alors c'était la deuxième solution
puisque vous êtes j'ai fait un film qui
est sorti en mai et là bientôt il ya ça
ira mieux demain de jeanne labrune qui
va sortir au mois de novembre
on savait déjà au moins trois films dont
vous n'êtes pas la crise d'un film de
toute façon alors c'est vrai que votre
entrée dans le cinéma est assez
illustratif des facéties du sort c'est
un une histoire assez incroyable parce
que quand vous étiez petit comme toutes
les filles voulais être actrice vouliez
être viviane lit dans autant en emporte
le vent
les filles veulent certains garçons qui
va être vivienne l'île n'ont pas ça je
dis je veux dire aux parents que c'est
un peu plus compliqué voilà mais bon
alors
donc vous laisse m'enfin bon c'était pas
non plus évident est l'année du bac vous
commencez à faire un petit peu
défiguration comme ça n'ont jamais fait
jamais fait de figuration jamais fait de
castille et c'est à dire que on m'a
proposé un jour de passer un casting
pour la figuration et moi aussi bas août
est tant mieux je vais me faire 500
francs pour marcher dans la rue aux
journées voilà mes copines qui se prend
ça semble marcher pour sas en france
vous connaît ah ouais vous pensez que
vous allez traverser l'eau et comment tu
obéis quoi oui ça avait un peu plus
important en fait c'était le c'était le
premier rôle quoi de l'android cédric
kahn ou vous fait tourner la tête de
deux hommes un peintre un prof de philo
face et le roman de moravia quoi porter
à l'écran vous ai tenu pendant pendant
tout le film
bien leur en plus qu'il faut dire là
maintenant vous avez beaucoup minci mais
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque vous sortez
d'un chagrin d'amour
vous aviez pris 10 kilos non je vous ai
tout dit un non mais je le sais vous
étiez baby sitter avouera trappier sur
le goûter des enfants gouverner non
quand on est baby sitter gère les
enfants qu'elles gardent et il était
comme ça que c'est aussi j'étais grasset
chagrin d'amour non ouais mais ça
s'arrange et depuis ça a l'air vous êtes
responsable à vous mais moi je m'en
souviens plus mais bon il ya vingt ans
que j'ai pas eu de chagrin d'amour tu
t'étais venger sur le lobby belge
comment fait sérieusement dans votre
famille beaucoup de beaucoup de gens et
votre nom d'amy peinture des peintres je
le fait de poser nue ce n'est pas un
drame
c'est pour ça qu'on est là si c'est pour
si ça rentre dans le cadre d'une oeuvre
et tout ça pique ça me dérange pas si je
vais pas poser nue là sur le plateau par
exemple ah bon catherine pas du tout ce
qu'on avait dit oui énormément
et puis c'est moravia quoi c'est pas
c'était très bien de films mais aussi la
duperie de luxe n'est pas par hasard
c'est un très bon film mais c'est
pendant le tournage s'est tellement
libre avec votre nudité que vous oubliez
de remettre le peignoir entre deux
prises c'est pas ça c'est à dire que
j'aime pas trop faire des chichis comme
on dit c'est à dire l'idée qu'il ya des
gonzesses ça c'est le son côté je n'ai
jamais joué lui voue gérard darmon
non je joue avec un petit à petit le
petit string de la cité de la peur du
tonus dans les pruneaux j'avais marqué
13 juillet n'ont pas la réponse mais la
question c'est quand même qu'il faisait
rire je vous avais oublié vraiment de
vous réveiller après comme si on oublie
de se rhabiller après la prise non mais
chacun sait les terres au gaz ou les
crédits dont vous avez été incroyable
faisait été choisi par cédric kahn au
milieu de trois mille si c'était pas
et on a lu beaucoup c'est vous qui l'a
choisi et au moment où on faisait deux
choisit donc ces seuils c'est le rêve
absolu tout s'écroule non c'est pas
exactement ça racontez-moi donc en fait
j'ai passé un premier essai j'ai fait je
suis plus quoi un texte du roman je
crois de moravia et là j'étais prise
mais parmi cinquante filles on va dire
et là ça s'est arrêté pour pour cause de
production et une peau nue en quoi donc
ça laisse après six mois après où jr
fait quand même trois quatre essais dont
charles berling et tout ça est au bout
tu sais ça marchait vous avez été
serveuse dans un quick vous avez
travaillé euro disney c'était avant
pendant ou entre les deux j'avais pas
continuer alors dans le costume de tic
ou de taxes oui elle est éthique et à
carreaux disney effectivement mais sinon
il est sympa maingot dans la vie on
connaît est ce que vous pouvez faire ce
que vous préférez plutôt ou plutôt bon
et là le film se fait donc le film sur
des cannes ce fait vous déboulez dans le
cinéma français c'est vrai qu'à une
époque avec des actrices c'est pas un
peu aride quoi on peut dire comme
sandrine bonnaire ou juliette binoche je
vous arrivez super pulpeuse comme ça
sans costume d'écureuil croisette
et donc voilà non ça a été un choc parce
qu'on était plus habitué aux blondes un
peu généreuse quoi ça sert caisses du
coup on propose que ça et c'est un peu
dommage quand on voit que comme jeunes
filles sexy et c'est pas du tout envie
de faire comme ça ça y est je pas ma
serial-killer mais sexy aussi donc c'est
ça qui vous embête c'est quoi le côté
sexy c'est le côté que voilà vous êtes
juste sexisme aux rillettes ses avocates
sexy serial killer sexy partout pas pas
faire ça moi là la potiche vous êtes
magnifique dans l'ennui vous n'êtes
jamais impudique derrière même si vous
êtes premier tout nu comme disait
l'autre
vous avez déclaré l'impudeur c'est pas
détenu sur un écran ces deux clones et
des oreilles d'hommes sur des rats je
savais qu'on allait me l'a ressorti
juste qu'il a écrit et l'autre là vous
pouvez y aller
bon alors à faire un peu de promo
maintenant 1 avant je faisais pas ça va
le faire ça moi j'ai très petit bras
dont jaar xfx avec c'est très vexant
pour moi j'avais pris mais j'ai très
petit bras je vais essayer mais c'est
très vous allez essayer oui c'est déjà
mieux alors se fit guillemin vous êtes
membre du jury du festival international
du cinéma au féminin du 18 au 24
septembre d'arcachon 1 la présidente
c'est dominique sanda je crois dans le
jury vincent elbaz laurent malet et
c'est des films en compétition comme
dans tous les festivals et aussi des
films hors compétition et d un film qui
fait l'ouverture c'est un film vous
jouez qui est le fils de jeanne labrune
il s'appelle ça ira mieux demain
de quoi ça parle vous verrez
d'accord d'accord d'accord attends toi
c'est pas un mauvais gars tu peux leur
répondre mais j'aime beaucoup mais je
n'aime pas trop raconté way
j'adore moi par exemple quand je vais
voir un film au cinéma je vous posais la
question imbécile de la télévision mais
tant pis pour vous vous y êtes à votre
avis sophie guillemin qu'est ce que les
femmes apportent au cinéma on est
tranquille pendant 10 minutes
si tu as besoin d'aller faire un tour
ouais un peu café elles sont plus
observatrice
elles ont raison elles ont plus besoin
de raconter ce qu'elle voit et de presse
que raconter leur vie en fin de ce
qu'elle ressemble à quelque chose de
plus personnel et voir le long du mall
intellectualiser elle raconte drômois
premier degré tout ce qui leur arrive
je ne réponds pas j'ai rien entendu mais
les hommes fonctionne plus sur
l'imaginaire sur leur sur la fiction se
trouvent ces annonces une bonne réponse
questembert public ça fait bien comme
très bien ce qu'ils ont pensé gérard je
peux je peux te fait d'accord mais on va
dire oui comme alesi donc qu'est-ce que
les femmes apportent au cinéma je trouve
déjà glocer de distinguo ces jobs et sa
non je maintiens festival international
du cinéma au féminin ils le font à
l'instar go soit moi qui les fais là
justement c'est ça que ça vous remettez
en cause vous absolument
il est sympa distinguo
ça c'est drôle on peut applaudir par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
merci sophy l'humain
alors maintenant je vous faire une
interview première fois en à bouche
pendant le qinghai
[Applaudissements]
bon état ou première fois c'est facile
un rôle à la première fois la fao fait
la première fois votre premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir de quoi de votre
vie la mienne dit d'armand oui
effectivement votre premier souvenir
vous étiez tout petit petit petit petit
je me souviens que j'étais amoureuse
d'un garçon en maternelle qui
ressemblait beaucoup au prince dont est
à mot ce qu'en dit vous allez le dessin
animé et moi j'étais amoureuse du prince
donnerais tu es amoureux ce qu'en dit
parce que j'étais un peu comme candy est
donc ce petit garçon la maternelle qui
était réelle ressemble beaucoup à ce
garçon que ça plus antonio être comme ça
et donc j'étais absolument amoureuse de
lui c'est fou mais j'avais meilleur ami
quête amoureuse lui aussi est donc on
les cours et après toutes les deux comme
des hystériques de maternelle et on lui
montrait un petite culotte sa as
ça commence fort votre premier péché
péché oui j'ai véniel un péché mortel
mon premier péché
le premier est de l'avis de gérard ou de
la sienne de la vie de sophie le premier
péché premier péché mais gégé pas vous
le dire
voici maintenant c'est un truc ouais
hein tout seul donc c'est bon on a
compris votre premier amour donc si je
vous ai dit c'était le petit anthony la
lafa celui qui ressemblait au prince
quoi si on appelle ça un amour ouais
mais après il ya votre premier amour
amour quoi
ouais c'était qui disent le nom le
prénom et son nom qui s'était même je
vous dit pas le nom et le prénom c'est
un mec
ouais ça va être un peu long de
l'accouchement va être un peu difficile
mais on va y arriver
non mais bon un mec d'accord mais à part
ça quoi ça c'est quel âge vous aviez 15
ans à 15 ans de premier amour c'était 15
en quoi c'est trop tard moi je trouve ça
un peu tard non
quant à 16 ans moi j'attends d'une vraie
histoire je parle pas des petites
amourettes oui d'accord d'accord
bon disons 6 à 15 ans que tout ça s'est
passé quoi un ouais bah voilà première
fois à 3 3 en trois sets
quand on était à 2 c 15 ans on passe à
15 ans et demi dans cette poule à ce
qu'on va passer à 15h30 vous gérez à
part dans la première fois passer des
camps dans les années 70 moi je me moi
je réponds parce interview la pression
est sûrement là elles sont là qu'on a
traversé les années soixante dix
première fois à trois points à 4 voilà
c'est à peu près le même parcours que le
vôtre vous faire mieux pour vous est la
première fois qu premier chagrin d'amour
donc oui donc c'est celui où les gâteaux
baby sitter voilà d'accord j'ai compris
10 kg d'accord ok j'ai compris première
tentative de suicide sagem et pourquoi
vous avez jamais ici de vous suicider ah
non jamais sa musique le nutella satu
quo
[Applaudissements]
non madame de fontenay appelle son mari
de catherine ce serait bien qu'on vient
vite zappé longtemps c'est quand tu
aimes dit catherine dans l'oreillette
merci qu'elle avait entre deux gendarmes
pour nos inquiétudes
alors bon première première cuite je
sais pas vers 16 17
c'est avec le premier la torche et
ensemble bien mon bon non pas le match
quand tu es demandé sa première cuite il
m'a dit je m'en souviens pas j'ai dit
pourquoi il va livrer j'étais bourré
premier pétard c'était avec lyon c'était
la bonne époque j'étais là il fallait
vous connaître en fait première ligne
jamais très bien c'est bien vous avez
raison
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant à pisser que je me
bats les couilles
pas du tout votre dernière volonté si
vous deviez mourir pisser
dernières volontés si vous deviez mourir
passer une soirée radars
et j'accueille maintenant mon invité
suivant le mozart de l'humour
pierre palmade
ban
cabanas bon soir vous connaissez j'ai
rarement puisque vous avez fait un livre
avec lui dont on parlait tout à l'heure
voilà je préfère avis alors pierre
palmade vous avez déclaré
c'était dans le midi libre alors je
pense que moi tout ce qui est dans le
midi libre je pense à pastis mans donc
vous avez déclaré
la télé est incontournable pour un
comique pour être connus mais attention
à ne pas tomber dans le piège du
narcissisme jaton pas plus drôle que ça
c'est pas ça là je vous avertis faut on
va être narcissique vous allez
narcissique là parce qu'on va parler de
votre livre à paraître votre spectacle
on va parler d'eux on va parler de vos
films on va parler de votre vie privée
de votre vie intime des lieux calmement
sexuelle
je comprends pas vous ayez pas fait
cette chanson vous parce qu'un fan de
claude françois comme vous êtes fait dix
ans que je fais le con claude françois
dans les émissions de télé non je vois
le mec qui fait ça il ya ni placer la
dengue est maintenant d'environ deux
millions d'exemplaires le mec dit on va
faire un peu de promo bien alors vous
êtes co auteur pierre palmade d'un livre
donc il s'appelle tu préfères avis chez
michel lafon avec un sketch on a écrit
ensemble
si je dois mon dernier spectacle voilà
donc alors j'ai pas j'en dis au hasard
comme ça il ya tu préfères raser les
murs avec un rasoir électrique avec un
jeu table voilà c'est le genre de
question je préfère avoir les jambes en
gelée de groseille ou les mains en laine
vissé tu préfères tu préfères tu
préfères mais pour toute la vie faire
sentir venir le danger ou sentir les
pieds voilà voilà ce que tu préfères
pour tout l'avenir il faut pas répondre
alors on va regarder le parce qu en fait
au départ effectivement comme vous le
disiez ça a commencé par un par un
sketch pour votre spectacle de l'an
dernier au palais des congrès salle
bordeaux et le skate il s'appelait les
choix michael bond toi finalement tu as
choisi de porter des lunettes écoute
s'il était saoûl anti tache d'huile et
lunettes
c'est courageux courageux d'avoir choisi
mais là où jade mire c'est d'avoir
choisi entre lunettes et lentilles moi
je m'attache non moi j'aurais pas suivre
j'ai pas pu lui mais leur dis là moi
j'aurais choisi je suis franchement
secours tentent maintenant tu pouvais
porter des lunettes ou porter des
lentilles statut répond de l'ue est
alors très très bien pu répondre à la
franche mois pour moi ce genre de
situation c'est l'horreur
ah non je jure par exemple sait pas
aucune devant vrai parce que tu me
demanderait 10 novembre
4 tu le voudrais par hasard pas par
exemple toi tu peux faire avoir des
dents en bois ou une jambe en mousse je
saurais pas quoi te répondre
après toi seulement si tu préfère
aborder dans leurs bras ou une jambe en
mousse box est pas toujours facile à
aller voit que c'est pas toujours facile
tu peux faire tu préfère avoir la grée
toute ta vie tu guérit jamais ou avis tu
as 30 cana qui tue pas
a pas d'atteinte à pour la grille
d'accès ce pas mais quand canal partout
des masques en place parce qu'on a par l
on doit l'être je suis papa et dans un
lit tonga
alors tu m'étonnes maintenant plus et
les choix que j'ai pas envie d'avoir un
bon où les accrochages
j'allais trop bon ok mais voilà tu
préfères avis avoir une tête de veau ou
2 bras 2 9 m comment ça c'est pas aussi
si cet été vous j'aime ça attention à
tout cas ça coince toujours toi on te
reconnaît yvon jours normalement mais tu
as une tête de veau ou de brown la
semaine on va te répond pas tout de
suite parce que après ces avis comme des
lunettes bien ce que je donne à ceux qui
ont passé des mre a dans la tête de veau
ça fait plaisir à voir de brad 9 mètres
plaisir à personne d'avoir de branne 9 m
imagine pour dire bonjour même pour ce
ballet c'est l'horreur non tout le monde
tu peux faire ça ou ça tu te réponds tu
es obligé de me répond ça ou ça casse et
qu'il en est
il n'y avait même pas bougé alors tu
peux faire tu peux faire à vie toute
façon ajoute bien sûr l avoir à la bande
window greffer là comme ça chaque fois
que tu parles d'un roadster de tap
voilà pnue
alors ils n'ont pas de nom pas la tête
des petits veaux qui viennent d'être
annoncés non non la tête de veau budget
qui est lisse d'un radier la tension
persiste en face on la tête de rousseau
quotas donc extrait de tu préfères avis
chez michel lafon donc effectivement il
ya eu les sketches sur scène qui
continue dans votre nouveau spectacle
continue dans le premier édile voilà
premier a dit on va en parler alors moi
j'en ai noté une s'est tu préfères
chaque fois que tu arrives entendre
tiens v'là l'autre qui arrive vous
chaque fois que tu pars conquis samba
voilà c'est là dedans voilà donc le
principe est simple vous pouvez acheter
le bouquin jouer chez vous ça c'est
vraiment un truc à manali c'est parti à
faire peut en inventer gens vont jouer
chez eux vont d'abord jouer celle là
puis ensuite ils vont inventer ça il y
en ad interactive ainsi recoller on en a
commencé quelques unes et puis il faut
il sous l'ailé compléter quoi j'ai donné
du mal pour faire ses bouquins à oui oui
j'ai combien de pétards un bouquin comme
ça c'est pas d'armes enfin vachement
agen wind ont même fini à marrakech dans
la poche trône ri quand même
ok on va parler de la scène maintenant
donc ça effectivement il ya un an un peu
moins d'un an des 199 vous étiez au
palais des congrès vous m'avez manqué
alors vous disiez à l'époque oui
finalement je fais un peu les textes des
autres alors y ait plein d'auteurs qui
sont venus y avait ramzi avait jamais
aux rats françois rollin la mairie dis
donc ça c'était l'époque il faut que je
dépasse mes amis mes amours mes emmerdes
il faut que je sois un peu acteur des
sketches des autres plutôt que auteurs
et puis quand on vous parlait à l'époque
de gérard louvin vous dis-je rahim a
malmené me parlez pas de gérard louvin
que ça c'était il ya un an
bon maintenant on est un an après alors
louvain est plus du tout quelqu'un qui
vous a malmené c'est lui qui a trouvé le
titre de votre prochain spectacle un peu
et réconciliée bien sûr ces délais
phrase on avait dû avoir des mots et
bing la journaliste appelle m
c'est toujours pareil donc là maintenant
vous êtes réconcilier bien sûr et puis
donc il a trouvé le titre premier
premiers adieux
ga et alors là pas du tout là c'est à
dire que d'un seul coup vous revenez
beaucoup plus vert vous même nom c'est
en fait c'est cyclique chez vous il ya
des périodes de vous éloigner de vous
détendre vous revenez vers vous non ce
que je me s'occupait pas mal du comédien
avec les textes inspirés par d'autres et
puis je me suis rendu compte qu'il ya
plein de sketches qui me manque vraiment
à moi donc j'ai fait la part des choses
et parce que je préférais du
vos photos vos spectacles qui a aussi
bien les choix qui était un spectacle
dernier que le scrabble qui est un grand
classique de pierre palmade c'est ça
voilà ouais donc c'est vraiment les
adieux c'est une espèce de tout ou quoi
les premiers jade view c'est mai dernier
début si vous voulez mais lors des
adieux à 32 ans après 12 ans de scène
y'a comme aux arcs est parti plutôt que
vous aujourd'hui lui c'est mais c'est du
moins ce que je fais je pars pas
vraiment un bon d'accord maintenant mois
ci au l'ag de celle là non mais alors
j'ai retrouvé un article du parisien en
92 alors c'est pas dit que c'est ces
premiers à deux pas du tout parce qu'en
92 il déclaré dans le parisien de 24 ans
pas prendre de haut ils disaient ouais
la cigale et là il va retourner à la
cigale la cigale ce sera un peu mes
adieux au one man show à 24 ans ont
précisé les mecs qu'on fait des adieux à
24 euros
non nous en connaîtrons jamais dit des
conneries alors donc vous reprenez des
premiers adieux d'abord en tournée du 3
octobre au 20 décembre
voilà octobre novembre décembre en la
france
avant ils connaissaient pas les mois il
a fait des progrès que les séparer dates
de cette tournée palmade
maintenant il a vachement beau c'est là
et je te tuerais la cigale du 21 au 31
décembre pour les fêtes de fin d'année
voilà ainsi à la cigale donc j'ai de
nouveau plus ça redevient plus
personnelle une certaine façon quoi
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire en ce
moment même le savent a fait souffler un
jeu un peu mieux alors comme moi j'ai
commencé il ya 20 ans j'étais un peu
vert comme comédien il ya des sketches
qui mais qui mérite une seconde chance
ouais et alors vous adaptez absolutely
fabulous qui est une
une série culte anglaise way qui ne
servira pas vous connaissez vous donc
fait ça avec l'avion clients daguillon
j'ai fait [ __ ] douce avec lui semblant
mais on sent une série comique anglaise
qui a beaucoup de succès à ces deux
femmes déjanté qui ont du mal à vieillir
et ils font entre toutes les conneries
mais bon un extrait de l'original
s'appelle absolutely fabulous
c
chérèque
mais bravo c'est un pad c'est génial
pour moi les équivalents françaises
passaient pierre je vous demande et
ainsi qu'à laurent baffie d'ailleurs
c'est avoue d'ailleurs si on avait eu
une blague c'est pour faire mon
enchaînements vous avez une blague a
raconté jean bart alors c'est un mec il
va pêcher sur un lac gelé
oui alors il fait un trou dans la glace
il pêche mais c'est un cadre comme ça et
il entend au bout d'un an
une voix qui fait et bientôt le poisson
il y aura le poisson on se pose trop de
questions il va un peu plus loin il fait
un autre trou hermes à cannes comme ça
et ça recommence au bout de cinq minutes
il n'ya pas s'il n'y a pas de poste qui
dit bon ça va bien maintenant beaucoup
plus loin il a fait introduire mais sa
canne et là il entend encore et après
qui sait qui parle
il entend le directeur de la patinoire
à aller bien au delà vous avez vous
jamais les longues ces domaines qui sont
bourrés bien qu'il est infléchi et ma
femme quand je vais rentrer à bas encore
m'insulter sont peu de lima la raison
d'insultés j'étais vu rentrer bourg et
amis comment tu rends toi tu fouilles
dans la serrure du réveil tout le monde
tu as dû nous tous tu renverses les
meubles si ce soir tu fais attention qui
choisit bien tacle et une allée me rien
d'une bouscule pas les meubles tu va
directement dans la chambre tu n'aimes
pas tu te déshabille et là tu te glisse
sous la couette dans le noir est une
bouffe le cul de ta femme jusqu'à temps
qu'elle prenne son pied et après je peux
te dire tu iras dans le frigo prendre de
bière elle te feras pas la moindre
réflexion et le type des musées salles à
ces défis c'est ça qu'il faut faire les
rendent chez lui respire un grand coup
il choisit bien saclay il fait pas de
bruit il rentre il bouscule pas les mobs
il va dans la chambre il n'a lui même
rien il se déshabille il se glisse il va
sous la couette
il ay comment ça vous fait de sa femme
une demi-heure bouge pas une heure et
commence à se réveiller
1h15 il sent qu'elle est réceptive et
une heure et demie elle explose sous la
couette et la fière du devoir accompli
se lève il va dans la cuisine boire sa
bière il arrive dans la cuisine goy sa
femme et lui dit mais qu'est ce que tu
fais là
ledit chamoin fourier maman qui dort
dans l'achat
bon alors justement donc je répète nos
amis téléspectateurs ce que j'ai dit la
semaine dernière ça qu'on va on lance
ici tout le monde en parle
le championnat de france de blagues dont
vous êtes chez vous vous connaissez une
super bonne blague comme celle qu'on
vient d'entendre vous demandez à votre
voisin de vous filmer avec son dv là
vous les adresser à la grèce qui est en
bas de l'écran pendant jeudi qu'ils
adressent pas à vous adresser à histoire
d'en rire tf1 news vous les avants et
c'est donc à tout le monde en parle à
l'adresse qui s'inscrit pendant que je
le dis alors les meilleurs sont
diffusées dans l'émission et les
meilleurs des meilleurs viendront les
raconter en plateau évidemment pendant
l'année voilà ça s'appelle qui veut
gagner des millions
exactement clarens mais c'est pas de
blague vous sophie barthet là vous aurez
pas besoin déjà massivement attendez moi
je suis très galant vous savez je garde
les femmes pour là pour la bonne bouche
je m'en souviens qu'à moitié
essayez donc en fait c'est un mec qui
est qu à témoin de grosses couilles cinq
minutes reste de ma faute
[Applaudissements]
il parle tout le temps comme ça dès
qu'elle soit embauché et dès qu'il y ait
remonté à peu il bâille pas normalement
et ça le dérange parce que dans la vie
la mort le parlait tout le temps comme
rozoy énorme et donc il va voir un
chirurgien pour lui faire enlever un peu
de ses testicules et est alors le le
chirurgien qui est un homme donc que
quand même assez surpris qu'on veuille
enlevé parce qu'il a quand même des
prestations au lit et superbe quoi les
13 par milliers tellement sûrs
surpuissant il dit mais vous êtes sûr
quand même que vous les enlevez de votre
virilité et c'est c'est eh oui oui j'en
ai vraiment marre joyeux de ballack
cette voie comme ça bon d'accord si vous
insistez ok je vais faire l'opération
aujourd'hui et revenez dans quinze jours
me voir donc il fait l'opération tout se
passe bien bon il a un peu moins de
maîtresse il un peu moins un peu moins
de succès au lit mais bon il parle
normalement comme tout le monde est très
content mais il revient quand même voir
le chirurgien au bout de quinze jours
pour voir si tout va bien elle est
suivie et tout ça et il fait bon jour
mais sur le chirurgien donc j'avoue voir
qu'on m'avait demandé au oui
ma jument de la paix
voilà
[Applaudissements]
avec leur panier
j'aurais tant les numériques vous
méritez charme
non en fait il les agressait attendait
oui j'en ai aussi qui me revient car
j'ai fini on va raconter c'est le sait
le sait un camionneur hockey mineur qui
est comme ça dans son camion qui roulait
et tout à coup sûr le bord de
l'autoroute il voit une femme sublime
qu'est en train de faire du stop
il arrête il ouvre la porte et vous
allez où je vais à lyon c'est votre
route ça m'intéresse il va dire aucun
problème je vais à marseille
elle monte elle s'assoit à côté sont
très très belle gonzesse qui roule comme
ça et au bout de quelques quelques
minutes comme ça la femme commence à en
savoir un peu choquant s'est déshabillé
allez dire faire des caresses rhône et
il est sur la routine il est comme ça
elle quand on voit comment s'allume une
petite main sur la jambe y rouler
roulent dont elle fait va se fatiguer ya
pas une cabine
oui c'est une gamine a juste derrière
elle va dans la cabine il est comme ça
derrière la cabine elle commence la main
dans les cheveux machin il bronche pas
ils branchent pas au bout d'un mois on
en a marre elle s'endort
il arrive à lyon il a réveil il fait bon
c'est là on est à lyon pour aider sans
elle descendra merci merci au revoir et
puis bon de temps pire voir et elle sent
là il reprend son camion et reprend la
route il sort de lyon ils s'arrêtent un
troquet lee randone dans le café il voit
le patron il fait qu s'allume valu dix
sept bières c'est le blay que tu fais en
effet 17 2 me mais ne cherchent pas à
comprendre les serres du st 2010 et demi
comme ça il est bois les 17 qui remonte
dans le camion
saint-louis roule comme saab entre bout
300 mètres comme ça il voulait comme ça
il sera garni fait t'as pas bondés
jusqu'à lyon puis sera pas jusqu'à
marché
ça promet donc si vous avez les mêmes
cas n'est-ce qu'un et vous nous les
envoyer bon pierre palmade dont vous
êtes né à bordeaux on va parler de vous
là
oui
ça à bordeaux en 1968 et d'une famille
classique de la gauche bordelaise moi
c'est ça permet de 101 plutôt de gauche
mais refait ministre 1
et arrêtez votre mère était vraiment
sympa avec vous parce que j'ai regardé
l'eau du rhin fréquence tard vous étiez
avec laurent boyer et votre mère disait
vraiment à votre mère était d'un laxisme
avec vous c'est vraiment à 68,1 disait
j'ai installé pierre près de la porte
pour qu'il puisse sortir ça c'est pas
mieux la maman qu'un seul son fils
prenne la porte qu'il faut il veut
sortir le soir le pot vous avez de la
chance vous en pensez pas l'air donc
vous êtes un vrai enfant de 68 élevés
sont trop d'autorité et non bah oui oui
mais j'ai eu la malchance d'avoir un
père keke décidé tôt oui c'est vrai que
ça d'un seul coup vous avez plus
d'autorité ou suivant oui c'est vrai que
j'ai tissé télé-chefs très tôt chef très
tôt déjà vos parents il n'était pas
spécialement sévère en plus votre père
qui disparaît donc vous avez dit
d'ailleurs quand votre père a disparu je
n'aurai plus jamais personne au dessus
de moi quoi surtout de trouver très
jeune très libre est ce que c'est cette
espèce de de liberté normes tout de
suite qui vous qui vous a fait détester
ou le fait de pas avoir de père que vous
avez une détestation de testostérone
carbone mat c'est à dire que vous
détestez tout ce qui est autorité tout
ce qui est macho tout ce qui est
masculin violent oui d'aidé qui a
quelqu'un est donc un homme revendique
une ici pas le rester
j'aimais 6 à des jouets sexuels c'est
vrai que parce que mr fcc la formation
votre mère qui était féministe et tout
ça en bâtiment et puis c'est une façon
de la défendre en plus vous arrivez à
paris faisait 19 ans mais comme vous
avez été élevé un petit peu d'une façon
un peu laxiste vous dites d'ailleurs je
suis arrivé sans repères ni du bien et
du mal et je me suis cogné dans les murs
parce qu'effectivement dans ces cas là
qu'est ce qui se passe on apprend par la
méthode essai/erreur serre on fait plein
de conneries puis en corrigeant en
fonction des conneries qu'on fait bah
oui mais je suis arrivée d'une ville de
province est tout seul dans un dans dans
un pari qui est très joli mais aussi qui
est kim jong quoi un puits
et puis voilà et tout est arrivé très
vite vous avez le style est très jeune
bah oui oui je suis arrivé à 19 ans à 23
ans je faisais l'olympia oui c'est ça
alan quinze jours donc ça ça fait
peut-être qu'à tourner un petit moment
quoi ouais mais bon ça va j'ai des amis
solide justement l'équidé vous de
trouver dans dans vos amis chez vos amis
et vous avez déclaré une phrase que je
trouve très très bien vous c'est une
bonne leçon pour tout le monde ça
j'avais dit je fais en sorte d'être le
meilleur ami de mes amis bari série g
j'ai envie d'être vite vous dit que
finalement vous réussissez mieux dans
l'amitié que dans l'amour c'est à dire
que vous êtes incapable de réconcilier
sexualité amour ça vous pour vous d'un
côté la sexualité de l'autre côté
l'amour elle n'arrivait pas mais je
crois aussi que quinze jours on en
baissera avec les gens dont on est
amoureux on trompera peut-être un peu
moins sa femme quoi parce que l'info
n'en génère non j'ai dit je n'arrive pas
à respecter une personne que je viens de
baisers finalement maintien il ya la
sexualité et il ya l'amour voilà alors à
part ma vraie histoire d'amour avec avec
véronique
j'ai j'ai du mal avec avec leur s votre
mort mais bon vous allez un truc génial
j'ai connu ça une forme donc c'est bien
dans la série des grandes phrases délit
je prends plus mon pied à bgc à faire
l'amour en la pérennité n'en parlons pas
c'est ça vous est complètement étranger
l'idée de paternité là pour le moment ça
me prend de temps en temps répu non pas
ce que vous dites j'ai vu ma mère
s'annuler dans un amour absolu des siens
c'est à dire que finalement votre mère
est anéanti pour les autres comme toutes
les mamans ça fait vachement j'ai peur
de plus penser à moi j'ai comme eu ces
mots et c'est vrai que c'est mon ego qui
me fait un peu faire ce métier j'ai peur
tout d'un coup bas de d'être à quatre
pattes derrière le gamin est
ouais c'est le dernier gadget de pin
vous avez du succès ça je comprends ton
qu'on essaie de réussir qu'on veut se
prouver et prouver qu'on a du talent
c'est tout à fait normal ça ne de ce
privilégié mais maintenant au point vous
en êtes d'énormément de succès j'ai ça
marche pour vous maintenant depuis dix
ans ce n'est pas gagné ça va quoi je
veux dire pourriez penser à faire des
enfants maintenant mais je sais ce que
je vais pas me donner d'autres non mais
j'avais j'en fais quand j'écris et
jean-marie quelque part fenninger
cerveau enfant voilà pour l'instant
vous n'êtes pas un peu être atteint du
syndrome de peter pan comme michael
jackson s'y refuse de lui refuser de
vieillir un comportement d'adolescents
d'enfants mais je sais pas
je sais pas grave le syndrome de peter
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
vraiment envie de grandir parce que je
suis pas fou de responsabilité d alger
suite non quand je suis sur scène je me
sens responsable responsable de la
soirée des 1000 personnes qui sont
venues nous voir c'est seul moment je me
sens responsable résultant si on peut
s'occuper du prosaïque pour moi je sais
mieux c'est qui on va recevoir
maintenant non celui que josé bové nous
avait fait oublier
il fait son come back à l'occasion de la
crise pétrolière
voici le président de la fnsea
l'aiguillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis au mans soir bon je laissais pierre
palmade
oui gérard darmon laurent baffie ce film
un nouvel essai du guyoult sophie c'est
le patron de la fnsea qui est un
syndicat d'agriculteurs évidemment qu'on
est plus josé bové on va en parler mais
lui c'est d'historique car cet acte actu
connais pas grand chose sur eux
je veux dire c'est une question j'avais
préparé pour vous je ne vous ai jamais
vu sourire et là je viens de vous voir
sourire c'est vrai que ça c'est à
l'arrivée une en plus de foot on passe à
taez non mais ça ne voulait pas tomber
au bon moment passé mais souvent on me
reproche que je brise et je n'avais vu
sourire
là je vois sourire ça me fait plaisir
aussi bas c'est réglé c'est tout ce que
je voulais moi les génériques fin et que
tu penses pierre qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent du bouc
moi je vais à super branché le bout
comme ça c'est ultra branchée lebouc en
fait non il est au top les jours à 6 ça
il ya plein de mecs qui mixe de la
techno toute la journée qu'on le crâne
rasé n'a pas le crâne rasé micon crâne
rasé une petite boucle comme ça ça vous
plaît
ils sont considère que laspalès pardon
lors je considère que l'asmo des savates
en avant si l'autre dites moi avant de
commencer tout de suite réaction parce
que ça s'est passé cette semaine trois
mois ferme pour josé bové à millau
françois hollande marie george buffet
robert hue on dit que c'était pas bien
vous vous a pas entendu un donc je
simplement dit qu'il y avait déjà eu pas
mal de soutiens de ceux qu'il soutenait
dans ses actions que bon maintenant il a
fait appel on verra plus tard
ouais pas vous le soutenez pas bon je
crois que je le soutiens pas plus qu'il
nous a soutenu lorsque notre ami car
elle était en prison alors je dois dire
que chacun a sa défense syndicale
je crois qu'il a il a commis un
démontage
d'un établissement il est en justice je
trouve quand même que la justice
française aujourd'hui n'y va pas par le
dos de la cuillère en ce qui concerne
josé bové mais aussi nous avons lu jean
pierre capelle qui a fait deux mois de
prison ferme n'est qu'au début de l'été
c'est quand même un peu dur sur volume
horaire bayonnais on ferait pas mieux
comme bien alors pardon laurent aurait
glissé un compte chez nous on écoute
bien alors vous sortez luc guyau le défi
paysans 1 c'est au cherche midi
voilà page 23 ça comment ça commence
fort
vous dites page 23 la sexualité au
milieu rural explose depuis l'apparition
des machines à traire tout à fait écrit
comme ça mais peut-être que l'évolution
technologique annoncé l'acea pardon en
avance et menacé les selles l'évolution
technologique permettra aux agriculteurs
d'avoir un peu plus de temps disponible
mettez vous à la place des machines à
traire finalement dans sa page 23 ans je
me suis trompé page 23 vous dites il
faut en finir avec l'image du paysan
plouc et cul terreux jamais plus nous ne
culpabilise rond sur les sarcasmes des
cyniques et l'image ringarde que donne
de nous les publicitaires 23 24 73
déguise en revanche c'est exact ce que
j'ai voulu dire par là c'est que
aujourd'hui on veut souvent donné
l'image de l'agriculteur du passé pour
vendre des produits
oui je me bat aujourd'hui pour dire les
produits y compris de qualité c'est dans
la modernité on peut avoir tout à fait
des produits modernes qui soit dans des
exploitations au moderne et avoir des
produits de qualité et faire croire
qu'il faut toujours que ça soit anciens
pour que ce soit de qualité
c'est une erreur parce que bien souvent
présente deux des individus qui n'existe
même plus une agriculture qui n'existe
déjà les agriculteurs comme dans les
pubs bien a pu en fait moyenne moins en
moins ouais et moi je rêve toujours d'un
agriculteur d'une agricultrice
d'ailleurs qu'ils présenteraient ces
fromages en disant mais voilà que j'ai
géré mon exploitation avec avec mon
ordinateur et je suis branché sur le net
et ça existe déjà pour vendre un produit
c'est ça aussi l'agriculture de demain
pas tous mais c'est ça je viendrai d'où
elle milite elle ya déjà
non mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai les
agriculteurs moi je les vois en
normandie
ils sont sur le tracteur avec le
portable n'y a pas de nom pas encore la
télévision parce qu'ils sont quand même
obligé de regarder l'arrêt va être
forcément faut tourner sinon des gps
maintenant ah ouais non mais je vois que
vous êtes bilingue au gps l'événement il
ne bouge pas au gps ne feront leur
culture en fonction de la qualité du sol
ils peuvent demain à porter des hangars
des produits phytosanitaires en fonction
du manque du sol donc relié par hagetmau
le seul parce qu'ils dosent les dés
demain donc sérieusement j'ai adoré ton
bouquin jeu j'étais trop jeune pour noël
dites-moi quand on compte dans les
salles aujourd'hui vous êtes lentilles
josé bové s'est pas seulement une
formule de style médiatique c'est qu'en
fait c'est vrai lui c'est avant c'était
mieux plus ça va moins c'est bien vous
vous dites aujourd'hui ça peut être bien
en gros quand je suis un peu méchant je
dis comme ça nous on défend
l'agriculture de 21ème lui reste plutôt
dans le 19e mais non mais je crois que
l'on défend pas la même type
d'agriculture nous on veut une
agriculture qui soit vraiment au coeur
de la société
ce qu'on appelle à un mot barbare
assurer la multifonctionnalité olala
temps des moluques
oui c'est ce que je fais moi quand vous
commencez vous me faites un discours
politique c'est ça
et vous allez être mosaïque et en plus
attention hein pas de discours politique
sinon c'est i muvrini et mosaïques et
pêcher là en vacances encore j'en ai pas
large bien alors alors donc on dit
l'image du bon vous refuser cette image
comme ça un peu l'image d'épinal du
paysan tel qu'on le voit dans la pub etc
mais votre père en fait alors c'était
que votre père lui c'était vraiment
l'image d'epinal il a bourré peau de
pair avec la dj vais encore avec des
combats revenons à ces gens qui nous
intéresse on trouve un vétérinaire a pas
d'autres perles à bourret a créé voilà
alors pas chemin royal et photos quand
même partie bois avec des chiffres il ya
un bandeau sur les yeux sans père non
mais vraiment son père c'est vraiment
votre père excusez moi c'est vraiment
l'agriculture c'est tel qu'on l'imaginé
c'est un feuilleton de tf1 il à bourecq
des chevaux et des boeufs pour des
nobles vendéen
donc il peut céder pas la terre c'est
qu'on imagine bien c'est terrible cette
histoire non mais c'est pas terrible du
tout si ce seuil est pourtant qu'il a
passé sa vie là pour aider jc la ville
et 9 le vendéen
mais tous nos pères nos parents ont
travaillé il ya 50 ans dans ces
situations là non en espace des 50 ans
l'agriculture a fait des progrès avec la
fée la science en cinq siècles l'aï
travaillé pour les nobles vendéen
simplement par le fait que nous sommes
fermiers dans l'exploitation avec mon
frère de père en fils depuis 100 ans est
le propriétaire je pas à vous demander
de trahir un grand soleil pourrait dire
c'est qui alors des propriétés vivier
non philippe de villiers nous avons une
famille de nobles qui était à la base de
la prestation de ses portes et vous avez
certes en fait pas tout à fait quand
même parce que la line up j'arrive qui
nous loue est il était un il était
ingénieur dans une mine en alsace alors
dites moi avons eu la crise
du prix du carburant la queue quand même
fait beaucoup parler le carburant
augmente alors que le revenu agricole
est descendu de 10 pour cent
quatre-vingt-dix-neuf donc ce n'est pas
rien 10 % de moins que l'année d'avant
fin je suis ta ville le calcul ça fait
rire ça lui parle bien les dispensant
des draps vient à l'école c'est pas ça
c'est qu'ils aient des 10% c'est ce qui
donne à 100 on n'a pas ça il va très
bien ce que c'est vous avez fait des
vous avez fait des barrages la faillite
chauffer 1
ça a été ça même chauffer un peu quoi
c'est bien parti
alors ça commence à part tout va bien ça
y'est bras de fer avec le gouvernement
enfin
et puis d'un seul coup samedi dernier
vous rencontrer le ministre de
l'agriculture jean glavany et la sortie
vous demander de lever les barrages
est ce que vous pensez pas luc guyau que
finalement vous et demandez un peu trop
tôt la levée des barrages parce que
regarder maintenant ça s'enflamme dans
toute l'europe c'est vrai on aurait pu
faire une révolution européenne me faire
la révolution c'était pas forcément
l'objet ce qui nous importait et nous
c'est de faire réduire de réduire les
charges des expos temps pour éviter
justement que les revenus de 2009 baisse
alors nous avons fait des actions toute
la semaine si le gouvernement avait
négociée plutôt plutôt que de commencer
le jeudi et puis le vendredi peut-être
que nous aurions obtenu coire et obtenu
quoi nous avons obtenu quelques
réductions de charges sur notre fuel et
puis nous avons prennent armes préserver
non c'est pas énorme passé compte tenu
de l'augmentation du fuel c'est quand
même pas grand chose par rapport à ce
qu'ont obtenu par contre nous avons
obtenu un négociations avec le ministre
d'agriculture pour parler de fiscalité
de social d'installation des jeunes de
politique de la montagne sérieusement
cuba il faut il faut continuer à
travailler pendant là on va se dire la
vérité vous croyez pas qu'ils ont un peu
roulé dans la farine la vanille on verra
ça plus tard puisque on a un rendez vous
maintenant le 15 octobre on travaille si
le 15 octobre vraiment on se moque de
nous on sera le dira d'accord alors j'ai
dit pas quand barrera les routes
ménagères quand même je prie ne vaut pas
de blanche-neige taqwa comme power
on s'était fait [ __ ] ttp nick et moi
c'est vrai j'ai encore mon vous qui avez
des peut dire des plantations énorme en
bolivie qu'est ce que l'on vous
réussissez en tant qu'agriculteur vous
réagissez comme ans
faire d'un point de vue jacques métais
hommes appartiennent et que tout soit là
moi comment vous expliquer la bouvet
mania c'est à dire d'un seul coup au
salon du livre
chirac arrive il se jette sur josé bové
il l'embrassait ils lui demandent de
dédicaces et de lui dédicacer son livre
comment vous expliquez ça cette espèce
dangoumau comme ça qui a eu pour josé
bové qui les a mis à côté pardon avec
mère katherine qui habille les trois
côtés des ouais c'est ça c'est pas passé
tout à fait comme ça au salon
d'agriculteurs bien sûr il est allé voir
josé bové et irrespectueux de la
représentation nationale mais il était
passé quand même prendre un verre de vin
de corrèze avant au stand de l'iphone et
cela donc oui aussi vous allez aussi un
petit peu quand même quand même eu un
petit peu bon et puis josé bové c'est
médiatisé très fortement dans le cadre
de la mondialisation et surtout pas s'en
aller en prison
il n'a quand même pas beaucoup qui se
mettaient à 10 ans en prison moi j'ai
toujours vu les gens qui allaient en
prison qui ne souriait pas beaucoup là
il était joyeux c'est un peu bizarre lui
moi je sais qu'il ya un sondage vous
savez l'année dernière en février dans
ouest-france quel est à votre avis
demandé le sondeur le meilleur défenseur
de l'agriculture premier bové deuxième
glavany le ministre troisième vous
emmerde ont quand même ça oui mais ça
dépend du jour où il fait le sondage sur
l'avait fait la semaine dernière petite
serait pas été la même chose
et puis ce jour là je vous rappelle
qu'il avait fait autant que le président
la république le premier ministre et les
mairies culture est une folle et qu'il
soit candidat à la présidence de la
république là il était parti là encore
une flèche
ah non mais attends à ce moment là ça se
dit ça c'est chaud c'est chaud donc page
103 vous dit
j'avais peur que tu abordes la page 33
je sais pas comment il va régler ça
parce que ce centre vous dit lorsqu'un
agriculteur rompt avec sa très lieu de
nantua page 103 vous disent se dresser
contre la mondialisation c'est dangereux
je comprends pas parce que ça donne plus
de pouvoirs au libéralisme sauvage
je comprends pas expliqué nous parce que
se dresser contre la mondialisation ça
devra enlever du pouvoir au libéralisme
sauvage pas lui en donner l'alarmé
justement vers lui la page sont tout à
fait là parce que on parle de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce est
derrière de mettre des règles pour
éviter justement que chacun ne fasse pas
n'importe quoi
quand on est contre l'om c'est
fatalement on laisse du pouvoir à ceux
qui sont les plus puissants c'est ce que
nous voulons pas nous voulons une
organisation du commerce qu'ils soient
bien encadrés justement pour éviter que
les tout puissants
enfin ne puisse pas le pouvoir c'est
vrai que bové a au moins eu le mérite
quelles que soient ses défauts et ses
qualités de remettre la cause paysanne
au centre du débat la preuve c'est qu'on
en parle
mais c'est vrai que vous le ménage et
pas vous dites est allé aux usa pour
faire son cinéma ce n'est pas ce qui
était quand même un peu vrai quand même
à l'époque faut quand même reconnaître
que arrivé aussi des impôts cinéma aux
états unis
avec 180 kg de roquefort c'est essayer
simplement passer un kilo à la douane
mais comment c'est difficile même une
pomme une passe pas donc tu chacun
défend ses opinions comme il le souhaite
nous nous on se veut on s'inscrit
beaucoup plus dans la durée dans le
pragmatisme pour chacun vous dites il
est trop perso en parlant de bové vous
dites ils jouent sur les peurs du grand
public c'est peur aux gens avec les ogm
et que le nucléaire est alors lui quand
il parle de vous il n'est pas tendre non
plus faut dire la vérité
le recul est il est violent il dit la
fnsea
c'est la mafia c'est clientélisme
d'ailleurs si on veut avoir des
facilités d'accès au foncier
ça aide d'être fn et cela parce qu'on
obtient les facilités d'accès au foncier
sert pour acheter des terrains il dit
c'est le sud de l'italie
il a quand même exagéré un peu quand il
a dit ça ce n'est pas vrai bon ceux qui
veulent se présenter
qu'ils soient des ranchers nouveau
ailleurs ils peuvent le faire par tous
les cas vous aviez écrit un premier
livre qui s'appelait la terre les
paysages notre alimentation vous dit
tout ce que dit beauvais était dans mon
premier livre repas deux pas de la même
façon pendant la même façon mais une
grande partie
et si vous ne me croyez pas à briser
l'on peut lâcher c'est le cherche midi
votre deuxième livre
a fait le lui planant sur
je ne m'attendais pas à voir un luc
guyau aussi souriant je garantis vous
avez vu toujours très comme ça fait
plaisir ça ma vraie nature c'est sexy
béton mais on est ravi de connaître
votre vraie nature dont peu défi paysans
cherche midi alors luc guyau la vache
folle alors là il ya un truc moi je vois
venir gros comme une maison
c'est à dire qu en angleterre il ya 180
mille cas et en france 144 donc moi je
dis que c'est le nuage de tchernobyl qui
s'était arrêté la frontière ces fameux
nuage de tchernobyl à la frontière ils
s'arrêtèrent d'alsace lorraine et nous
on a jamais on nous a jamais dit qu'il
était venu jusqu'ici
est-ce qu'on n'est pas parti dans le
même temps m mensonge c'est à dire
finalement chez 980 mille en angleterre
comment il ya une règle sans 444 en
france à metz
tout à fait c'est tout à fait normal
dans la mesure où les anglais ont été
ceux qui n'ont fait un peu n'importe
quoi en matière de farine de viande
animale
ils ont nous allons exporter ou si une
partie tout ça est arrêtée maintenant
depuis 90 et 96 suivre l'utilisation des
farines on fait des analyses n'en fait
pas des têtes sur des animaux vivants en
effet dts que j'allais me more alors ça
c'est plus gros problème mais il n'aura
pas la possibilité de faire des tests
sur des animaux vivants on va courir
encore la galère et c'est la galère
c'est qu'il ya eu alors j'ai maintenant
je vais je vais vous dire le scoop même
de la faire ce qu'on a découverte à moi
tu n'arrêtes pas le mad moi manger de
viande ce qu'on a découvert c'est que le
prion y passait de l'animal à l'homme
et aujourd'hui on est en train de
démontrer que le prion peut passer de
l'homme à l'homme tient ce prions espèce
de maladie de la vache folle maintenant
c'est plus seulement quand tu mange de
la viande c'est à dire que tu es en
[ __ ] tu peut choper un prion n'est
pas tout à fait rendu là quand même un
nom mais attention
et ce n'est pas mentir à la france jean
ba dans ce cas précis pour faire l'amour
un steak tartare donc ça pèche encore
très peu de gens bien on va faire
rentrer la vache on va vérifier tout de
suite
bon alors luc guyau maintenant je vais
vous faire un truc là vous allez être
obligé de répondre la vérité serre ges
que je peux avoir ma petite lumière
spéciale les tuyaux c'est la question
qui tue est-ce que vos enfants mangent
de la viande
oui tous est ce que c'est votre viande
ou ciel que vous achetez en barquette
dans la grande distribution
c'est en majorité notre viande mais il
arrive qu'on en achète aussi alex tai
chi vous arrive d'acheter de la viande
en barquette dans un supermarché de le
donner à vos enfants
oui vous avez pas peur non puisque
aujourd'hui on arrive à identifier les
morceaux de viande 12 d'où ils viennent
puisqu'on a réussi depuis deuxième
question les guyot est ce que vous aimez
vos enfants oui je peux même semaine
vous faire un scoop
j'aime aussi beau que mes petits enfants
parce que j'étais grand père le week-end
dernier c'est déjà grand-père besoin
cgem fois vous êtes un jeune grand père
quand même bien alors comme c'est samedi
soir pas se prendre la tête je vous
parle pas de la dioxine du poulet je
vous parle pas de la listériose
je vous parle pas des ogm démonstration
par des boues d'épuration sont le fera
la semaine prochaine
dans fuite d'huile au le défi paysans
voilà effectivement vous en tous les cas
vous fait un come back médiatique vous
m'aviez voilà on sera samedi par la
couverture et votre voix du sens aux
bouquins c'est très bien attractif ce
livre c'est il ya aussi du fond non mais
bon je te dis pour chasser les problèmes
auxquels est merci laurent et je veux
bien maintenant je vous faire une
interview nul en la bouche banking a
[Applaudissements]
souri ça fait plaisir de voir sourit
peut pas savoir je vous ai vu à la télé
plusieurs fois tu dis mais qu'est ce cas
là il est sérieux le pauvre c'est vous
qui fait la gueule maintenant pourquoi
il vous plait pas il vous plait pas dès
qu'il ya plus d'armes en vous il vous
plaît pas du bio mais si ce titre est
bien celui là tu as fait tu es tu as
fait une malheureuse histoire le carton
là ce que tu veux
dans son dernier mot
[Applaudissements]
assaisonner france a étendu sa
couverture moulard sont là et l'ange ans
bon attention luc guyau est ce que vous
préférez votre père votre mère mais il a
fallu les deux pour que je vienne au
monde donc les aime autant l'un que
l'autre
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline n'a que le choix ne se fait pas
ni je vous en faire une vieille ville
vieille c'est le vaisseau spatial vous
partez trois ans un vaisseau spatial ou
préféré partir avec d'armand palmade ou
sophie je partirai avec sophie je
pourrais tu fais la gueule tu avais dis
moi qui est le mot le plus con en amour
c'est merci encore où
oui oui ça dépend du jour sans doute
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
alors comment vous aimeriez mourir
maintenant attention parce que c'est
valable pour toi aussi pall mall labour
et comment vous aimeriez mourir comme
john lennon c'est à dire comme otis
redding c'est-à-dire crash d'avion comme
janis joplin c'est à dire une overdose
ou comme le chanteur décide ici bonne
scott est mort dans son vomi les 400
sympa mais c'est pas ça m'emballe pas
toucher les questions d'usagé de
répondre à vos mii c'était du bon
c'était là il est mort dans son vomi le
pauvre il a annoncé pas tellement pas
celle là
une overdose nopus et dans le crash
d'avion il faut être ça pourrait nous
arriver parce que je circule tellement
en avion que jamais donc vous risquez
que vous préféreriez le crash d'avion
c'est là que j'ai l'air non je suis pas
que je préférais me voir ça risque de
plus alors la question très très
difficile quel est l'animal qui embrasse
le mieux à louvain répondu mais moi je
pense que c'est l'homme
bravo ces lycées dont vous avez fait
exactement la même réponse que josé bové
jugement à venir jeter réveillère au
sujet
vous avez vu l'émission c'est pas
possible
moi je n'ai vu un boom j'avais pas vu
cette part j'ai pas entendu de réponse
l'homme quel est l'animal qui embrasse
le mieux josé bové répond l'homme et du
bio l'homme voulait comme quoi
comptez-vous attention là je veux dit la
femme mais bon tout casser chacun ses
goûts c'était avec un grand il reste pas
grave
le beauf et lexus pas tout non ça va
très bien pour lui vous cassez deux mc
donald's est une star je vous le dis
alors maintenant si la demande du public
parce que moi je vais arrêter de poser
des questions c'est la question clotilde
courau fameuse question qu est ce que
vous embrasse riez bonne femme mais
enfin les chaussettes de votre femme
salle 100 fois par amour je crois pas
même que je vais bien 100 fois les
chaussettes rendre à l'udc
et puis des billets la vieille halle
est-ce que vous préféreriez mourir tout
de suite tout de suite là vous mourrez
la hâte et vous aller au paradis où
vivait encore 30 ans et faisant affaire
il reste encore le purgatoire entre les
deux géants à la récupération il est
catholique kto ont alors fait pas alors
dernière question toujours la même vous
laver les cheveux tous les combien un
tous les matins non à la hogra toujours
ouais ça vous fait re s'est passé pas
très bien j'essaie de choisir méchant
coin parce que tu le vaux bien bravo
on voit maintenant la guerre
n qui cartonne voici zabel boulet
isabelle boulay bonsoir donc luc guyau
sais pas vous plaindre de la mousse
attendant voilà ça finit mal luc guyau
vous connaissez gérard darmon permanent
baffie alors vous confond beaucoup
isabelle avec des souvent avec lynda
lemay en aux enfants avec linda louis
lemay boulet canada tout ça est en fait
c'est vrai si votre chanteuse préférée
en fait mais c'est une de mes chansons
préférées
ouais c'est ce oui oui bon c'est pas
grave finalement ça me dérange pas bien
ça me fait plutôt plaisir vous a un peu
changé de look vous là parce que sur les
affiches qu'on voit là sur les colonnes
morris en ce moment vous êtes un peu
plus rock un peu plus urbain style un
peu rebelle coiffer façon à mylène
farmer avec le débardeur noir le
pantalon en cuir c'est votre conseiller
artistique qui vous a dit de faire un
peu plus rebelle c'est une photo de
seine donc c'est une attitude qui est
complètement différent ouais voilà vous
êtes pas l'accent quand vous chantez 1
non non vous l'avez quand vous parlez
parce que les chansons sont écrites en
français international je le chante je
connais un peu comme chez luc guyau 1
mais il ya beaucoup de gens de chez nous
qui ont déboulé c'est un nom c'est un
monde ici à boulay choisir l'homme fort
booléens ouais ça vienne de l'achat
c'est ça alors vous êtes né alors là
c'est la poésie complète vous êtes né à
sainte félicité en gaspésie re la
gaspésie south et du nom boulaq ici rue
la gaspésie ou encore je vous ou saint
laurent ouais à vos parents avaient un
restaurant avec un bar au sous sol
donc en fait débuté dans la carrière
quoi lâche 2 à l'âge de deux ans non
mais c'est la première fois que j'ai
chanté un public j'avais deux ans alors
vous avez fait des chorales les mariages
les balles et à septembre vous avez
gagné votre premier prix une bouteille
de vin oui
je suis allé voir je suis allé voir
l'aubergiste pour lui dire que moi
évidemment j'étais trop jeune pour boire
est ce qui pourrait me donner autre
chose
il avait donné 5 dollars alors vos vrais
débuts professionnels en fait c'est cet
art manière de lier l'âge j'avais j'ai
28 ans maintenant et en 2000 c'était 1
95 des vingt trois ans vous avez succédé
à fabienne thibeault à maurane dans le
rôle de mary jane de grosses on peut y
lire
et après il ya eu tout dire
[Musique]
m
tu te tais
c'est une chanson de plamondon et
richard cocciante qu'on fait notre dame
de paris donc c'est plutôt au départ
bonne qualité alors déjà quand j'étais
tout petit à sainte-félicité en gaspésie
là bas vous disiez à votre mère ça c'est
incroyable c'est vous ou à votre mère un
jour je chanterai à l'olympia c'est vrai
ce qui est fou c'est que le 4 décembre
là vous faites le vous faites le premier
olympia
oui c'est incroyable cette histoire non
basse et c'est pourtant vrai chez nous
on recevait on recevait le paris match
et ma mère écoutait beaucoup de chansons
françaises et chaque fois j'entendais
les artistes parler de l'olympia de
paris la piètre paris et je lui avais
dit moi aussi je veux chanter à
l'olympia de paris
et vous avez communion ce que voulaient
les chefs du thym truc ça se passe pas
forcément un jour je dise de moi un jour
je vais bien faites-le l'âge atteint les
jours
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
voilà un joueur des tout petits elle a
dit un truc a dit à sa mère je vais
embrasser luc guyau maman l'a fait c'est
dingue le savent bien et on vous dit
j'ai un truc vachement jolie vous disiez
quand vous vous étiez au bord de la mer
validé lumière au loin comme ça vous
croyez que c'est la france
oui parce que moi je demandais toujours
j'entendais parler de la france et je
demandais à mon père sait où la france
et visait la france c'est de l'autre
côté de la mer et nous on vivait face à
la côte nord est en fait de l'autre côté
je voyais les lumières au loin le soir
mais c'était une réserve amérindiens non
c'était pas des français étaient pas des
français bien vous sortez un nouveau cd
en luc tu qu'elle soit lente
bien le cd s'appelle mieux qu'ici bas
voilà zoom zoom bon garçon serge du zoom
voilà est le premier single c'est par le
mois
j'ai vendu un wagon non je ne sais pas
lire le single the rendu 40000 c'est
vrai avait jeté trop de modèles et leur
faisait beau chèque bruel qui vous a
écrit une chanson avec marie florence
bourg ici douteuses dont il vous avait
parlé connu avec l'ama ça s'est bien
passé avec la marne ont très bien très
très bien non regardez moi dans les yeux
oui très bien très bien très très bien
comme ça doit se passer de ses missions
discrètes vous avez vu un jeune homme
est sûre ça maintenant je sais m'arrêter
s'il ya quelques années je serais allé
comme un là maintenant je sais m'arrêter
mais annie encore deux ans merci pierre
me sauve bien alors vous allez partir en
tournée là en france au québec partout
avant cet olympia du 4 décembre et vous
pouvez tout seul parce qu'on tourne et
je suis pas tout seul quand même y ait
beaucoup de gens avec moi sur scène non
mais je suis en fait on avait ça l'avait
dit que non là c'est un problème là
non mais là c'est un problème parce que
je tiens à dire isabelle a dit je ne
connais pas de french lover je ne
connais pas de french bien fait pour les
italiens au niveau physique je ne
connais pas de friendster je lance un
appel ce soir vous allez dans un certain
nombre de villes en france donc il faut
que les gens soient au courant de ça
s'est passé ça quand même
mercer n'y a pas plus tard que deux
minutes comme un mail main voilà
sauvagement embrasser
merci
[Musique]
quand isabelle boulay mieux qu'ici base
c'est le cd et par le mois
[Applaudissements]
elle chante
il est exemplaire
merci on va accueillir maintenant un
académicien parce qu'il ya pas de dîner
en ville réussissant un académicien et
avec cela il ya toutes les chances que
ce soit réussi
voici jean marie rouart
[Musique]
non
jean-marie van soir jean marie rouart
vous connaissez tous le monde
donc jean marie rouart prix interallié
prix renaudot directeur littéraire du
figaro ou directeur du figaro littéraire
s'est pas complètement la même chose
écoutez on peut dire les deux je crois
oui c'est plus sympa de dire directeur
littéraire du figaro que je crois que ça
va beaucoup d'importance à 6 alors il
s'est donné un mal de chien pour pour
être directeur du figaro littéraire il
m'a dit que ça va pas la porte aux
attentions voix bon vous êtes le plus
jeune académicien français non vous êtes
un homme jeune bach scénarii les plus
jeunes que moi il est plus réputé le
doigt sur la blessure à ça commence mal
tout ça ça commence par une énorme gaffe
alors votre nouveau roman c'est pas une
autobiographie ça s'appelle une jeunesse
à l'ombre de la lumière
zoom zoom en garçons c'est chez
gallimard c'est pas une autobiographie
puisque c'est des épisodes de votre vie
vous avez choisi les plus romanesques
donc c'est pas une vraie autobiographie
en fait non vous savez moi dans la vie
ce qui m'intéressait c'était le roman
oui c'était vraiment dû dévier dans
l'écrire mais ça a été surtout en vivre
ouais et
ce qui m'a amusé c'était de revenir à
ces instants qui sont surtout des
histoires d'amour
et puis il ya aussi des échecs en
réalité j'ai connu beaucoup d'échecs et
ils vont en parler commencer par
l'autodépréciation ça c'est son grand
truc il un grand truc ou war c'est que
le mec il est juste académiciens il à
tous les prix tout mon ex un grand
écrivain et de priorités il passe son
temps à faire de l'auto dépréciation
attention un trait passion à déglinguer
nos bons donc c'est ce qu'on peut dire
votre bouquin jean marie tu sais que
c'est le roman d'une vie vous racontez
pas votre vie vous donnez votre vision
de la vie en fait beaucoup plus que la
raconter comme ça c'est vraiment fumier
fumier c'est que oui en effet c'est ce
qui m'a intéressé 1 urs ça m'embête les
gens qui parlent de leur vie est très
souvent on y raconte pas ta vie
ouais quand les gens racontent des
choses ennuyeuse et parfois en parlant
de sa vie on arrive à dénouer des deux
notamment dans la vie amoureuse wiki ce
pape qui se passe pas toujours bien et
notamment la mienne quand j'avais 18 ans
oui autant ça marche très bien
je vais amener le meilleur académicien
français le plus sympa là j'ai pas mais
d'un bien en a d'autres aussi des gens
très sympathiques
bah oui nous y atteler maintenant je
peux le dire la mettant au goût si tu
n'aimes pas non d'ailleurs ça vous
l'auriez pas écrit avant d'être academy
j'aurais tête écrit différemment et
c'est vrai qu'un débit donne de la
liberté oui bah oui maintenant vous a vu
ce que vous voulez rire ce que je
voulais c'était la liberté mais vous
l'avez bien sûr vous alors donc vous
prenez le prétexte dans votre bouquin en
fait c'est la narration de la vie d'un
peintre qui s'est suicidé au début du
19ème s'appelle léopold robert en fait
vous l'abandonnez assez rapidement un
seul et au polar bear du revenue de
temps en temps mais enfin c'est pas
quelques en fait je vous parlais de vous
parler de votre père et dès la page 27
vous rentrez dans votre sport favori
dans quel l'autodépréciation alors c'est
extraordinaire cette espèce de
d'autoflagellation comme ça vous dit par
exemple je pioche est en moi même comme
un chercheur d'or et je me trouvais pas
de pépites je me trouvais que de la boue
la fin
l'autodépréciation la satisfaction c'est
la satisfaction
donc je suis je dirais que ce n'est pas
de l'autodépréciation c'est simplement
je crois en fait un peu de la
mégalomanie
c'est une énorme ambition je suis
toujours insatisfait je me dis j'aurais
pu faire mieux j'aurais pu être malraux
j'aurais pu être mauriac
j'aurais pu être des gens formidables et
je le suis que moi vous allez ça me
déprime
voilà des gens qui sont très contents
avec une légion d'honneur ils ont
enchanté moi ça nous satisfait
vous avez des phrases terribles y
présente les succès passe les échecs de
moeurs et ça c'est vrai mais tout le
monde dirait le contraire
moniot les échecs france et succédant à
part ça je suis sûr c'est qu'on a deux
frères
on interrogera ici tous les gens qui
sont sur place
sur le plateau il est ce qu'ils disent à
ce qu'il le souvenir qu'il garde ses
souvenirs des prix sur des femmes qui
l'ont aimé qu'ils ont quitté sa vague du
back raté celui qui a eu les gens
croient pas qu'ici non c'est ça qui fait
kiffer de l'année
excusez moi j'en mette en mer 20
le regarder isabelle ne regardez pas
trop où jean marie rouart parce qu'en
général on succombe très très rapidement
et je pense pas qu'il ait le temps
d'aller en tournée en france en ce
moment cette attitude que vous avez
jean-marie un petit peu hautaine comme
ça de tous oui c'est un peu tout obtenir
pour pouvoir tout méprisé que votre
devise d'ailleurs est ce que par rapport
aux vrais malheureux vous trouvez pas
quand même que ça un peu choquant par
rapport aux gens qui ont des vrais
malheur parce que vous vous y êtes
malheureux bon ou bien vous croire aux
gens qu'ils sont toujours là au chômage
qui sont malades et bien vous savez je
pense que mahler est immense et que
chacun ses malheurs les malheurs
sentimentaux ne sont pas les malheurs
qu'il faut mettre de côté on peut être à
la fois est au chômage et malheureux en
amour je crois que cette assistance qui
lie à sur les questions amoureuse c'est
vrai que les écrivains on peut dire que
ce sont des gens favorisés
ce sont des enfants gâtés c'est vrai oui
ils sont gâtés mais en même temps c'est
pas pour ça que leurs valeurs sont ils
intéressants parce que ces malheurs
quand il les analyse ça nous fait du
bien
moi personnellement quand j'étais
plaquer eh bien je lisais la prisonnière
de proust le ça me faisait du bien et
jacques culteurs qui se fait plaquer
pour du prozac un écrivain est fait un
best seller dans ce livre jean marie
voir vous parlez de votre famille alors
évidemment vous êtes de la partie fauché
mais en fait c'est quand même grande
famille vient pas d'une famille fauché
par léman brièvement coupée à votre
famille essaie de nous dépeindre avec
tous ces pins tous ces gens comme ça il
ya beaucoup de peintres way he et aime
trop c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé la
fuir justement l'écrivant les romans
alors une avait énormément il y avait à
la fois mon arrière grand père qui était
peintre était le meilleur mine de gars
qui a fait son portrait il y avait
un de ses fils qui l'épousé la fille
berthe morisot donc était la nièce de
manet c'est vrai et cette nièce de manet
il était maintenant de julie avait été
élevée par la ville comme tuteur
mallarmé renoir mais tu vois c'est vrai
que c'était formidable
meas époque là je voyais pas comme ça
parce que j'étais intoxiqués par la
peinture tout le monde parlait de
peinture à table votre vie est à table
on ne parlait que quand on voyait
arriver les pêches ont des âges des
gardes pour sa nature main était alors
été très le poisson regardez pas oui
alors effectivement vous êtes chercher
une autre famille avant vous ne pouviez
plus vous êtes chercher notre famille
alors vous trouvez nulle quoi tient vous
ratez votre bac vous dis tu faucher je
suis infréquentable veut dire que votre
père vous parlez beaucoup de votre père
dans ce bouquin huit façons il se fout
de tout ce qui n'est pas la peinture un
mode père c'est à dire que lui et qu'une
chose qui l'intéressé quoi on peut dire
que c'était une espèce de d'adolescents
prolongée et dès qu'il n'avait pas
d'argent il avait chez son père quoi et
surtout le dtc le succès c'est pour ça
que je suis devenu un arriviste ouais il
noté tout à l'heure en effet moi j'étais
fasciné par le succès social je n'en
reviens pas parce que je vis des prix
littéraires et vous annonce ma seule
ambition à l'époque jules c'était
publier un roman et ce roman était
refusé par tous les éditeurs 13 x 13 x
et donc vous imaginez les femmes qui se
barrent leur banque est refusé c'est
vrai que vous avez eu comme ça des
échecs fabre sur papeete du siècle henri
troyat refuse que vous soyez sans son
biographe
après vous entrez au figaro vous dis
toute façon le figaro faut être nulle
pour y aller ceux qui en sont ceux qui
ont échoué partout il ya un truc marrant
au figaro c'est la bella va nous la
raconte et se raconte et celle-là gens
bien c'est juste un miroir arrive au
figaro tout d'assurer tout raté donc
c'était d'après lui l'endroit où on
finit il finisse et les fils de famille
que vous avez tout raté et là vous vous
allez à la rubrique religieuse et vous
tombez sur un abbé un peu ah oui un abbé
qui me regardait qui est un homme très
gros et très rouge et qui me regardait
un regard exalté et qui m'invitait à
prendre des cafés c'est qu'on est
stagiaire grand journal mais très
intimidé et à chaque fois qu'il en est
pour un café ils avaient la manie de
serre et la cuisse très près et je
sentais que ça se rapprochait j'étais
très inquiet parce que j'avais peur
qu'ils me disent du mal de moi donc je
vais me voulaient absolument entrer dans
ce grand journal très prestigieux et
puis un jour dans l'ascenseur il s'est
rapproché de moi et j'ai vu ses yeux qui
est dardé à feu extraordinaire et il m'a
dit vous n'avez qu'un mot à dire
je vous fait rentrer la rubrique
religieux et à ce moment là l'ascenseur
s'est arrêté et andré frossard est
rentré heurté la providence il m'a sauvé
du déshonneur
mais enfin oui pour un arriviste j'ai su
refuser oui c'est vrai je suis on verra
après modération refusé pas mal de trucs
d'air alors autres initiations après
l'initiation pédophilique c'est la
maçonnerie vous êtes vous ne savez pas
du tout ça dans votre père devait être
fou de rage femme que vous soyez je lui
ai jamais dit ah ouais parce que mon
père qui était camelots du roi qui était
tout à fait méritée monarchiste en
enseignement à celle qu'elle était il ya
deux ans mais en fait ils refuser la
réalité et l'idée de rentrer maçonnerie
est tout à fait contre la maçonnerie
c'était pour lui ça se passe comment
alors rien l'initiation maçonnique ça se
passe comment est ce qui m'a intéressé
mais c'était prendre des libertés vous
avez cette famille et la maçonnerie
c'était un peu l'interdît et ça m'a
passionné
ça m'a passionné parce que à la fois
c'est rentrer dans un univers symbolique
moi j'adore le symbole j'adore les
mythes et en même temps c'est rejoindre
l'antiquité c'est rejoindre que les
initiations antique avec la musique de
mozart
c'était très beau c'était magnifique et
même temps je vous fais parce que nous
on sait pas qu'est-ce qu'on fait bloc
vous arrivez que les yeux bandés mais je
bandais oui les yeux bandés
vous avez le pied nu ce des chaussées
vous avez l'épaule nu et là vous fait
passer par le bac n'est ni rature et
dans l'ascenseur carré
chez les francs-maçons alors voilà non
parce que passer par les baptêmes
parlait ouais non je peux dire c'est
qu'elle est qu'est ce que vous avez
appris lors de cette initiation que vous
ne sachiez déjà j'ai franchi un préjugé
la bonne voie c'est très important parce
que je me suis rendu compte que cette
idée qu'on se fait la maçonnerie qui est
quelque chose de très mystérieux
compliqué et d'un peu sombre au fond ça
c'est éclairé sur le compte que j'allais
faire des gens comme les autres et où
d'ailleurs bout d'un certain temps je
les ai quittés mais c'est vrai que ce
qui m'intéressait c'était l'aspect qu'il
n'y avait pas dans ma famille l'aspect
social combats sociaux
paris après je me suis lancé dans un
certain nombre alors page 280 là j'étais
scié
c'est la première fois que jaurès a
épicé
des cris c'est écrit un académicien
français qui dit pour la première fois
on est en l'an 2000 en même temps j'ai
pris du hbh ont jusque là c'est pas
énorme
j'ai prix de l'opium bon déjà vous soyez
un côté malraux kessel hemingway mon
corps se passe un peu j'ai pris de
l'héroïne vous est pris de l'hérault où
je le crois mais vous savez c'est une
époque où j'ai beaucoup vu mon frère qui
m'a écrit des livres sur la drogue et je
crois que c'est important là aussi
d'avoir cette liberté d'avoir tâté de la
drogue pour ensuite dire attention d'y
aller par un bien sûr à pour l'héroïne
bah ouais et d'opium et peut bien
prendre 2 0 quand même les routes cet
email rossé pires pages de la ville je
sais que marc a fait mais de l'opium
mois fabien ibarra fumée d'opium
refonder l'échelle des valeurs
mais vous dites d'ailleurs j'avais su je
n'ai pas fumé aux parents de l'hérault
but un truc tout à fait juste derrière
vous dit jamais je n'ai vu la mort
d'aussi près et ce qui est peut-être
pire la déchéance et vous êtes assez
enfin vous touchez puis vous repartez
tout de suite ça immédiatement et ça
vraiment autant alors j'aurai beaucoup
de compréhension pour les gens qui
fument 2h même de l'opium mais vraiment
qu'il en culture alors qu'à ce moment là
il ya vraiment une barrière un précipice
l'héroïne c'est tout à fait autre chose
et ça c'est d'un danger c'est un risque
fascinant inquiétant et ça je déterre
détournerait toujours les jaunards moi
je sais pas est ce que vous racontez pas
tout ça finalement pour vous faire
pardonner le côté académiciens couvert
de femmes romancier primé qui
fréquentent le gotha est ce que
finalement vous regrettez pas un peu
cette image un peu mondaine comme ça que
vous avez et vous dites je vais faire
dans le bouquin un peu l'héroïne là je
te curé qui veut me tout ça comme ça ça
c'est si vrai que ça vous rend d'un seul
coup plus proche de nous pauvres mortels
oui mais voilà ray hé bien vous avez
compris c'est un livre j'ai essayé de me
rendre plus proche de vous
j'ai essayé
j'ai essayé de le sortir des clichés
j'ai voulu montrer un peu que j'étais
alors ça paraît bizarre j'ai voulu
montrer ma vérité mais c'est vrai qu'en
général la croix ils pointent de
l'ecstasy demandé le je ne dénoncerai
personnes en fait si on voulait résumer
un petit peu ce que vous êtes vous êtes
un on pourrait dire un hussard et dieu
sait si vous avez aimé les urssaf les
chercher à les fréquenter vous racontait
les rendez-vous avec deon vous vous êtes
un hussard mais un hussard avec avec du
coeur d'une certaine façon peut-être un
besoin de justice que n'avait pas non je
pense qu'ils les usa avec beaucoup de
coeur mais il avait été moins cette
préoccupation sociale social et il
n'était pas passé par la franc
maçonnerie de réduit d'ailleurs que
j'allais bien mais qu'importe moi
j'adore digne et j'adore les bloody nasa
a été votre passé tôt vous dites je
rentrais à l'académie pour fréquenter
les gens que j'aimais lire quand j'étais
plus jeune félicien marceau c'est ça
s'était très romanesque
s'ils voulaient de retrouver les vidéos
j'avais vu 18 ans comme jean d'ormesson
en troyat ou revel kim avait engueulé
genre histoire c'est vrai que
quelquefois l'académie je veux pas mais
c'est pas possible je rêve je suis
devant ce alors que je les ai connus
quand j'avais 18 ans à l'époque où en
effet j'avais du mal à voir mon bac et
bien ça c'est très romanesque ça dans la
vie c'est ce que je recherche
j'ai essayé de montrer dans ce livre
c'est les instants où on retrouve le
romanesque dans sa fille bien alors ça
s'appelle une jeunesse à l'ombre de la
lumière c'est chez gallimard
vous avez compris ou comment réussir en
accumulant les ratages
alors maintenant
deux mois
jacques guy forget
guy forget bonsoir bonsoir vous
connaissez tous le monde
oui à peu près sophie sophie rechanter
donc vous participer aux huitièmes
compaq seniors c'est un tournoi du 14 au
17 septembre donc ça se termine bientôt
à paris au golf and country club et
c'est ça absolument
alors y'a kia mcenroe moi j'ai noté
mcenroe noah leconte vilas bahrami gomez
et pk ch
c'est bien beau plateau vous êtes
capitaine d équipe de france les filles
c'est la fed cup les hommes c'est la
coupe davis la saison 2000 a été un peu
un peu difficile non oui à un taux ça a
mal commencé déjà défaite d'entrée à
moscou 1er tour perdu par les garçons à
florianopolis alors j'ai eu un léger
mieux si vous maintenez dans le groupe
mondial c'est ça absolument pas
complètement éliminé qua non je pense
qu'on mérite notre place dans le groupe
mondial et on va jouer donc contre la
belgique au mois de février prochain
la france jouera pas la finale en tous
les cas cette année non puisque c'est
celle australie contre l'espagne paris
alors il ya de l'eau dans le gaz depuis
février depuis depuis cette histoire de
février là il ya deux langues avec
colleen quand même non non ça s'arrange
ça va ça s'arrange savez c'est jamais
facile de gérer cinq garçons qui ont un
usage différent de personnes qui est
différente des revenus différents puis
séparés aussi pour les filles mais c'est
je pense pense que pour ça tout
challenge est intéressant justement
arrivé avec pioline parce que nous on
l'a reçue ici
ouais bien sûr j'ai vu ce qui s'est
passé vous êtes frites et non seulement
je comprends mais je n'en parlais pas
mais là on en produit le cas nous
n'aurons fait pas du tout frites et je
crois que après la défaite de nice
l'année dernière contre l'australie il
ya certes un garçon qu'ils ont plus ou
moins bien vécu et lorsque l'on perd on
cherche tous un petit peu des
responsables et je crois que il y en a
certains qui ont pas très bien digéré sa
défaite qui n'ont pas assumé tout
simplement et je crois que lorsqu'on
fait du sport il faut parfois accepter
d'être moins fort que l'autre et puis
deux pas de continuer à avancer
dix mois il va jouer en équipe de france
pour la ccpo le mans c'est pas sûr
écoutez je mangeais aucune
aucune raison de penser qu'il va pas
jouer aujourd'hui je compte sur lui sur
tous les autres d'ailleurs vous
intéresser tennis darmon non ça me brûle
ça me rappelle quand cette semaine où
l'on sait mais ça m'intéresse pas c'est
peu dire j'y étais liste on peut
attraper ce cancer dans son coin et puis
c'est tout oui c'est très bien
conservant davantage d'être drôle alors
non merci je dis pas que le tennis soit
le sport que je préfère me ya tout de
même une chose dont je voudrais parler
ça ht peut-être un petit froid c'est que
je trouve totalement injuste la
non-qualification de tauzia haut pour
les jeux olympiques de de sydney de
nathalie tauziat et j'en parle sur la
pointe des pieds puisqu'elle avait l'a
pas dit des choses très très aimable à
votre endroit comme les nôtres ex et ex
président de la république donc voilà je
trouve ça je trouve ça anormal qu'une
joueuse qui a été classé e3 de numéro un
mondial et les meilleurs résultats si je
peux terminer un vaste et gentil ne soit
pas ne soit pas dans l'étroit dans les
trois femmes qui ont trois sportives et
trois athlètes qui ont représenté la
france
alors est ce à cause du du bouquin qu'à
la sortie c'est ça c'est parce que j'ai
ce que dit ce qu'est ce que dit forget
moi je veux enfin je les lui j'espère
que vous vous dites
elle peut pas comme ça passait son temps
à attaquer tout le monde pour nico va
pour l'argent une autre pour ses cibles
pour cela donc à un moment il faut
qu'elle le sait ça non non je reste un
petit peu maladroit de sa part de sortir
ce bouquin ce moment là maintenant on
peut pas penser que un livre puisse
occasionner sa non sélection
oui oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui le
pense je crois qu'il ya un flou par
rapport aux critères de sélection les
critères sont là était vraiment
mais c'est nettement bon scène entre ces
résultats c'est vrai que c'est vrai mais
ça nous fait pas plaisir de on espère
que ça va changer
c'est vrai que pour le moment tauzia bon
elle fait chier kournikova passer la
côte d'argent
fait chier testud parce qu'il y est
toujours blessé et vous vous dites en
parlant de pioline je peux pas me
permettre d'avoir une diva dans son
équipe une vive est d'un mot l'équipe
bon donc c'est vrai qu'en ce moment il
ya un peu de voilà quoi
ça balance pas mal voilà à quoi ça va
pas fort en ce moment à passer par
rapport aux olympiques lui dire bon
c'est pas du tout ma décision dire
j'étais bien content de pas être
impliqué dans ce dans ce choix là mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est regrettable
je n'y sois pas en plus a très bien joué
effectivement à l'us open
c'est un sale caractère un atelier à
l'aller venu dans l'équipe dans l'équipe
elle n'est pas facile à gérer
qu'est ce qui donne envie de le dire
dans la presse d'aider des saloperies
sur les autres ça qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent qu'on soit je crois que c'est ça
un peu rapace par rapport à son livre je
crois que si on s'amuse en permanence à
bas par les défauts des uns et des
autres je crois qu'on se fait des
ennemis finalement je crois qu'elle a
beaucoup d'autres choses a raconté
nathalie que que les petits les petits
travers de ses camarades et je crois que
souvent avec toutes les parties un petit
peu de lâche moi et c'est bon c'est je
crois que c'est regrettable moi je crois
que tout le monde parle de ce livre et
personne ne la lui surtout vingt six
mois j'ai eu est venu ici je peux vous
dire qu'elle balance c'est l'apogée
notre carrière c'était 91
oui ces quatre quatrièmes au classement
atp c'est plus haut vous soyez monte pas
mal la coupe davis est plus prestigieux
que d'être numéro 4 quand même ouais
ouais ouais il a gagné la coupe aussi de
fonds va regarder tout ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est beaucoup l'air
merci
mais ces managers 0 pleine errance
sa fille
[Applaudissements]
cc
c'est ce soir
[Applaudissements]
guy forget 1991
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça bon tout allait bien et en jeu
près bon d'être passé comme ça
progressivement de 4e à 169e eh oui
connaissant malheureusement elle
puisqu'il monte redescend absolument et
à un moment où vous avez été voilà vous
vous dites pourquoi se cacher la vérité
c'est en 97
bien sûr j'aurai des sursauts évidemment
mais ça sera plus jamais comme avant
vous aviez mal c'était ou au genou n'ont
connu beaucoup d'anti-inflammatoires je
t'ai opéré puis c'est vrai c'est ça
puisse arranger pas quoi et alors voilà
vous avez décidé d'arrêter puis vous
êtes devenu finalement vous avez pas
cliquer le tennis est devenu le
responsable de l'équipe de france vous
un côté très jean marie rouart parce que
il se plaint toujours voir et vous
pareil vous dites à par 11 victoires en
tournoi et deux coupes davis
ma carrière est jalonnée d'échec on
attendait oui bien sûr enfin bondé quand
même gagné deux coupes davis et onze
victoires en tournoi oui c'est vrai
j'étais frustré parce que j'ai joué
pendant 15 ans un niveau professionnel
c'est seulement sur les trois dernières
années de ma carrière avant ma blessure
où j'ai atteint j'ai mon meilleur niveau
et je regrette de pas avoir pu jouer
j'irai ce tennis l'a beaucoup plus tôt
malheureusement j'avais pas encore mais
l'hiver c'est bien sûr donc moi je me
suis arrêté donc sur une blessure
j'étais 11e mondiale quand j'ai arrêté
et c'est pas quelque chose qui est
agréable
de vivre à ce moment là quoi quand on a
son sommet a eu des hauts et des bas on
va faire l'interview à peine dans la
bouche par le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous préférez en vo ma bonne
humeur ce que vous détestez en vo aux jo
no way bonjour j'ai été sur ce que vous
préférez dans le tennis
la variété de la variété du jeu 1 ce que
vous détestez dans le tennis
la longueur de certains matches 1
ah oui c'est vrai mais pour nous aussi à
contrer devant la télé laquelle journal
est déjà passé de but mathieu maintenant
un ça va mieux maintenant avec les
nouvelles règles en plus des nouvelles
sont bonnes plus gros coup de fric en
plus beaucoup de fric ce soir vous avez
gagné beaucoup d'argent non sérieux vite
réglé de l'argent ouais ouais 6 millions
de dollars en prize money sûr que sur 15
ans de carrière et les 6 millions de
dollars ouais ouais ça fait quoi 30
millions cette année
oui tu vois les [ __ ] la drogue ça va
vite sur une carrière non c'est beaucoup
d'argent
vous êtes tranquilles en fait ouais non
c'est vrai je me plains pas les acheter
le plateau mois et peut-être pas vous
aussi si vous croyez vie beaucoup plus
france de bons votre plus gros coup de
fric vous l'avez dit c'est très honnête
votre plus grosse perte
non je ne crois pas au jus de perdre le
ballon va ce prix là maintenant il peut
pas là pour faire une berthe votre fils
marc et dans la ville
ces millions de dollars et l'a dit non
au cusm à rennes on le le sourire de
gosse peut-être ce qui fait le moins
rien dans l'hypocrisie et baffie et
baffie votre plus belle histoire d'amour
vite passé vous parce que j'y croirai
pas non celle que je viens à l'heure
actuelle avec ma famille mais ça fait
quand même temps 11 ans de mariage et
15-16 ans de vie commune et d un truc
très beau sur mathieu sur votre fils
vous dit quand je rentre et que je perds
à j'ai perdu un match et que je rentre à
la maison
lui il me regarde toujours pareil et
source assez c'est assez joli ça je
trouve ce qui est le plus sexy en vous
que c'était 6 millions de dollars ce qui
est moins sexy en vo c'est moi de moi de
répondre joueurs de champ non non ça va
je me trouvais que je me trouve tolérant
je me trouve à je me touche mais tolère
dans le miroir me plaisait quoi vous
êtes bien comme mec y en a c'est reparti
on a compté pourtant donné un traitement
entre ces îles et non attendez
sérieusement isabelle il non il est bon
oui maintenant qu'est ce que c'est il a
les yeux
merci je trouve que vous préférez dans
le sexe le goût allez vas-y vous
préférez dans sexy sérieux l'intensité
way est ce que vous détestez dans le
sexe rien il n'y a rien qui me manque
imaginaire adm vous entendez un jeu par
là toutes les françaises la gare à qui
je parle bien je vous remercie en
rallumant pasteur teste
et on je demande aux gagnants de la
semaine dernière puisque telle est la
nouvelle règle du jeu le gagnant de la
semaine dernière me rejoint s'il vous
plaît voulez-vous me rejoindre bon voilà
donc règle du jeu est très la règle du
jeu est très très simple c'est à dire
que donc les invités répondre si les
invités ne trouve pas c'est le public
ici qui peut répondre
et quand quelqu'un du public trouve il
peut revenir la semaine d'après tu
t'appelles comment michael comme la
semaine dernière c'est génial bien
michael donc tu es avec moi et tu peux
revenir la semaine prochaine si tu les
baisses d'accord ok bien il avait pas
les cheveux comme ça la semaine dernière
avec la photo n'est pas les jeux comme
ça c'est le script il part dans l'oréal
à la photo ah oui c'est vrai as tu été
rasé la tête basse et à dire que la
première fois qu'on se voit à la télé on
dit qu'il faut changer quelque chose
bien bien alors vous connaissez le
principe dit on mais des chansons mais
des morceaux et le premier qui trouve
bas gagner évidemment
donc c'est facile là comme vous êtes là
et comme c'est les jeux olympiques
évidemment on a fait ce sport et il faut
me dire l'interprète et jeudi didier
premier morceau
mais pierre palmade à bicyclette
à bicyclette
on change pas de sujet deuxième morceau
leader qu'est donc oui bravo long c'est
assez surprenant un canton les voiles à
y répondre et au bout de trois 3 notes
c'est un sans le son très étonnant
encore en continu dès lors ma fille
lennon et à deux
on passe le début et quand vous avez
reconnu on pas ce qu'on appelle la
révélation lui qu'il a tout de suite
remarqué on passe la révélation et donc
qu'on fasse évidemment le refrain pour
que tout le monde le reconnaisse à la
maison et au bon garçon la semaine
prochaine il faut que tu te 1
alors didier
véronique david robo michael
[Musique]
pardon pierre vous disiez c'est pourquoi
il rit mais comme c'est une émission
discrète on n'en parlera pas bien je
cache le fiche parce que oui tu as
raison catherine l'amicale il doit un
peu pour la suite le groupe i
l'apéro du char de hollande attention
laurent et fort la suite
[Musique]
l'interprète
diana ross mygale
seuls les juges
tiana les muscles barreau bicanic la
suite
[Musique]
tout d'abord les cagoules depuis
et soudain
chaque année j'essaie de faire chier la
mer égalité miquel et baffie donc c'est
un match terrible entre mon meilleur ami
et mon nouveau meilleur 9 on continue
ses villas chantait dalida l'interprète
bolling l'a dit
[Musique]
au niveau aaa
je
ici comme un rappeur magic doc gynéco
bah oui ses passements de jambes
elle s'y connaît en vapeur ce à quoi je
vais voulait lancer un groupe de rap et
vous êtes branché rappeur oui j'ai un
groupe de rap qui s'appelle à bout
portant que j'ai bientôt est lancé sur
la scène avoue c'est son prénom bon
c'est bon bon bon bref attention
maintenant donc le super banco pour
départager laurent baffie et michael ou
alors c'est pas parce que le défi
paysans savent encore le super banco
maintenant il faut me dire
l'interprète me donnait l'interprète de
cette chanson
[Applaudissements]
à
la mauvaise idée la mauvaise idée ça
aurait été dire gloria gaynor et mickaël
savez ces errements son coiffeur qui
hérite content et ses découvertes de
philippe corti que je salue ici
d'ailleurs voilà formidable bravo ben
vous revenez à cette prochaine
on applaudit michael qui est en passe de
devenir une star en fin de vie de coteau
voilà merci serge merci bravo à la
semaine prochaine très bien merci à tous
on rallume
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
je rappelle pierre palmade premier adieu
donc en tournée du 3 octobre 20 décembre
et ensuite à la cigale du 21 au 31
décembre avec le leap il a coécrit avec
jean rarement tu préfères avis chez
michel lafon gendarme en le lit donc
j'aime le dire lui-même balades sont mis
à deux ils pas nous les donner à 2 voilà
jean marie rouart une jeunesse à l'ombre
de la lumière chez gallimard
luc guyau le défi paysans au cherche
midi
voilà les guyot vous avez le boulet donc
le disque s'appelle mieux qu'ici bas et
le premier single s'appelle par le mois
en tournée en france et au québec elle
maintient à partir du 4 décembre
un membre du jury du festival
international du cinéma au féminin du 18
au 24 septembre à arcachon
et puis bientôt ça ira mieux deux jeunes
labrune autour du 22 novembre
guy forget 8e tournoi compact seniors du
14 au 17 septembre c'est en ce moment au
paris golf country club avec mcenroe
avec noah avec le ponde avec village
voilà il se termine demain j'en fais
vraiment j'ai péché c'était tout le
monde enfants rendez vous jeudi prochain
merci
à la pièce dans notre pays